good morning everybody
there's someone i'll call to order the
house criminal justice and public safety
committee before we begin
representative marston do you wish to
lead us in the
please allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
at this time we will now open the
establishing a criminal penalty for
denying an elected school district
official access to any school district
this time i recognize uh representative
i move out to pass and offer amendment
2022-0893h
is there a second
second
that motion has been seconded by
representative roy
representative wallace do you wish to
speak to your motion
uh
that
you should all have it do the members of
the committee all have a copy of the
amendment
actually i'm going to defer to
representative pearson to speak to the
amendment
do all members have a copy of amendment
0 8
thank you mr chair the amendment
covers
and adds a little bit of clarification
that's technically unnecessary but i
think it was done based on the
response i saw during the public meeting
this bill
addresses a concern that
is growing throughout the state of new
hampshire
rockingham county
but
throughout other parts of the state as
unfortunately we have situations where
folks who are elected by the people into
various positions are
being ghosted
due to purely political reasons
and this bill addresses
that that's not okay
i want to be clear that because some of
the concerns that were raised during the
public hearing that folks would have
access to things
that they shouldn't have access to is
completely unfounded this bill does not
eliminate any other statute it doesn't
overwrite any other statute so if
something is currently prohibited under
state or federal law it remains
prohibited
this doesn't change that in any way
so there's no concern that folks would
have access to personal student records
iep records
confidential faculty records none of
those those are all protected by law as
it is
and this bill does not change that in
any way but what it does do is it says
if you're elected to a budget committee
you cannot have a superintendent deny
you the budgetary documents you need to
function
if you are elected to a school board
you cannot simply be
kept from school property from school
events
because that's your job as an elected
official
i'll point out specifically in case
those are asking on line 17 the the
addressing of rsa 91 a5 sections three
five and seven those are law they'll
continue to be law of the whole
section's law but i added that just for
clarification
i was asked why number six is not
included number six addresses school
preparedness in the event of an
emergency and i think school board
members should absolutely be
an integral part of that the law doesn't
and
rsa and this was in the original bill
rsa 189 13 a that is the listing of
prohibitions to be a teacher if so if
you're certainly not qualified to be a
teacher
in the sense of you've been convicted of
certain things then you are
rightfully prohibited
from
being on
school property
that would prevent a say a registered
sex offender from being elected to a
school board
and having access
and that is what the uh the bill and the
does any any members wish to speak to
the
representative bourdain
thank you chair um
as much as i dislike this bill
this amendment is an improvement on it
and if if the committee is
determined to pass this bill
i want this amendment included so i will
support it thank you
yes my concern as a former
school board member
is that there's no time constraints on
this so if an elected
school board official were to go into a
high school in elementary school while
classes are going on
i don't know what their intent would be
to go into a class that's not and and
make a visit that's not pre-arranged i
don't have any problem if it's
pre-arranged with the teacher the
principal to go in and observe a class
whatever but just to go in i think is
disruptive given
the amount of curriculum all the
teachers have to cover
representative calmly
thank you mr chairman i
don't know why this bill was before us i
don't know why this
i guess i know why the amendment's
before us because it fixes problems with
the original bill we have not heard a
single reason why this
needs to happen
we've heard some anecdotes
from maybe one place
um
if there's personality disputes solve
them
we don't need to legislate what someone
must do
and we don't typically do that
anywhere in our statute that i'm aware
of
and we certainly don't make it a crime
so
unless someone has a reason a compelling
reason to do this i'll be voting against
representative ray newman
yeah
like uh representative borden a i would
probably vote for this amendment because
it improves the bill but i still object
to the bill
and line 11 um it just says
it says budget committee is that i
assume that that means because it says
school district position after that
i assume that means the school budget
committee so we're talking about
somebody that has to be on a school
board has to be on a budget committee
i guess that's the limitation that we
tried to get here
and the other question i have is
it says all school facilities it just
says
in the bill itself it says and it's not
amended by the amendment
it says that that they shall have access
to all school facilities
and
i'm just wondering if there are any the
school is a public building
but obviously i think there are spaces
in
any of the buildings
that are not open to the public and i
don't know why the school board member
needs to have
a have unfettered
access
to those spaces and i don't see that
improved by the amendment so that's my
representative
thank you mr chair um
i think i've had about 42 years in
education i was an assistant
superintendent
deputy commissioner
this bill
is
far beyond what i would ever have
imagined would be in place
i mean the right to know laws cover
much of what
this is asking for
areas since covid
there are
just a variety of different tensions
that that are occurring
from fragments within our current
society
to put a bill like this in on top of
everything else i just think is
unconscionable i definitely will be
representative roy
thank you mr chairman
as a current member of a municipal
budget committee
i can see the need for this bill because
you know when when people are saying
well it gives them access to all parts
of the school well the school is asking
for money and they're asking money for
the taxpayers for for certain things
and the school board and the budget
committees are the representatives of
the taxpayers the taxpayers certainly
can't
go through the school and look at
everything and and see why it's
necessary and not necessary those are
judgment calls that they elect people to
make and to bar the people who are
responsible for setting the taxes on
people from seeing what their money is
going towards is in my mind
unconscionable it's taxation without
representation they can't go in and see
what their money is being spent on its
secret where they're not allowed it's a
special place
we have these
few elected officials
that should be able to see
why the school needs money what it's for
and what's going on so i will be
representative conley
thank you mr chairman i know we don't
typically debate and i'm not intending
that but something the representative
just mentioned this bill goes a lot
further in the amendment
than just making facilities open
um
it says essentially they can enter the
school and do whatever they want in said
building whenever they desire it that's
it's not limited
to what
the member just said
that kind of
what he describes i think we all agree
would be
reasonable in most circumstances but
that those kind of limits are not
thank you
so the way the way the amendment's
written line 12 it says shall
be so basically it says any other
elected school district position shall
be denied access to any school facility
documents or school activities by the
superintendent
that does that's not saying that
a member of the budget committee or the
school board can just you know have
universal access to public schools at
any time in the middle of the night
that's not what it says
it's that they can't be denied access
so if a school had a role that you need
to sign in and to schedule a time i
don't believe that that would be a
the
bill is written before us right now
is if that there is no exception and
they just simply deny the person access
all together
and i don't i don't understand why it's
unreasonable if a member if if a school
is
you know advocating for you know a new
gym facility
or whatnot that members of the budget
committee would want to see the
existing facility
to be denied access i i'm curious why
people are opposed to allowing access to
information so people can make informed
decisions i haven't heard any reason why
they shouldn't be about access to this
it's
may i respond and the fact that it's i
hear that it's not happening i know in
in my district it's not happening but
it's i hear it's happening in other
other districts and members of this
committee it's happened in
in their districts so i'm just
i'm curious why that we would not want
to allow access
to the facility
mr chairman if i might respond that
limitation that everyone seems to think
exists doesn't exist it says shall not
or shall
you know no elected member of school
board budget committee etc shall be
denied access to any school facilities
it doesn't stipulate any kind of limits
as we heard from the member from nashua
there's not any kind of limit
that i think would be reasonable it's
that
those you know three to four words are
the problem with this bill and this
amendment
so you believe that if someone attempted
a member of the budget committee tried
to access the public school at three
o'clock in the morning that they would
be violent that would be a violation of
this law
as written
i think one could make that argument and
again
we haven't heard from a single member of
the public
or any budget committee member who has
said i tried to get these documents
i tried to get into this facility and i
was denied we heard any one single
anecdote
and i'm not sure why we're legislating
representative pearson thank you sir
a couple things
based on what i've heard um
you know we use the term space is not
open to the public recently here elected
school board members and school budget
committee members they're not public
they're elected officials and they're
elected officials that are over and
above a superintendent i think that's
where part of the problem here is is
that we've turned superintendents into
kings of their domain when in fact they
report they are subservient to the
school board and that's where we're
having problems here the second thing
under the right to no law an elected
school official should never ever have
to file a 91a request to get documents
to do their jobs ever
and the idea that that would be a remedy
and a
concept that would be used for these
people to have to perform their elected
duty isn't is just frankly
why this this is being written because
we're having you mentioned reasonable
okay
reasonable
sure there's a lot of things that people
would think would be reasonable but
that's not what's occurring and if you
want examples we have a budget committee
member in the north country that reached
out to me that was told shut up and
write the checks you don't get to see
any of the documents to verify
in my county rockingham county alone we
had a superintendent bar a school board
member from school property because he
questioned something in a budget this is
occurring it's happening it's
politically motivated and again we've
turned this on our heads this wasn't
done in the dark this was done with the
commissioner of education and vetted by
represented muse yes i i don't agree
with the member that this is politically
motivated but i think it's politically
motivated in a different way
um
this continues a pattern that we've seen
throughout this legislature
and throughout this legislative session
of
making school officials
and making administrators
adversaries
traditionally in new hampshire elected
school officials and school
administrators have been partners in the
same cause that's the way it's worked
here for years
now we're starting to see laws uh like
this
and we're talking about who's
subservient to who
um i think we need to kind of get a get
a grip on
on on reality and and get a grip on the
kind of situation that we want to have
uh going forward and uh as
representative conley said there are
serious problems with this amendment
there are serious problems with this
bill
the the original testimony
of
of the of the representative who came
before us
and related uh one anecdote
frankly
i'm not sure it actually helped to make
the point at all uh i mean what it
basically what it basically showed was
that the the person in question uh was
over the top uh with his rhetoric uh
talked about um uh you know even talked
about doing things like uh
you know i'll quote you from what what
it was said what he said he said
if uh
uh
the member said i was trained as a
sniper if i want to harm children it
would be while they were on the
playground this is a person that we want
to uh we just want to give a free pass
to school grounds
i think part part of this is um part of
this is just sort of symptomatic of what
we've been seeing this entire session
with attacks on public schools attacks
on public school officials
and i'm not going to put my name on
anything that gives
essentially gives people
the ability to divide us even more than
we already are so i'll be voting against
the amendment and i'll be voting against
represent representatives if i may just
inquire and
how have you how do you expect a member
of the budget committee to make an
informed decision
on a light item
if they ask or inquire with the school
for information and they denied access
to that information
i don't think we've actually heard that
anybody of that situation i mean the the
situation that we heard in testimony was
the one that i just told you
i mean
i don't know the way it works in your
cities in town but i mean if
if a school board member was to ask
somebody for information about the
budget or more information they make it
a point to get them to get them that
information and
sometimes they can't get it to them
right away they have to do some research
they have to look things up they also
have to look at things like
confidentiality when it comes to eips
and things like that
but i mean
this literally is a non-existent problem
made up in people's head and it doesn't
representative roy
thank you mr chairman i i wanted to just
address quickly um
the concern about this being
unrestricted access if we just look at
this from a commonsensical standpoint it
says they shall not be denied
so if i call as a member of the budget
committee and ask the superintendent i'd
like to come into the school and
look at a b or c
and he says fine next tuesday at one
o'clock he may do so
i go make a complaint to the court or to
the police and say i've been denied
access
i wasn't denied access i was told when i
could do it
denied access means you were denied it
doesn't mean that you were allowed and
there was certain restrictions to it
just means you were denied so this bill
does not give unfettered access as long
as the person is not flat denied this
statute would not be violated
so um the the this conception that
school board members would just be able
to walk through the school when they
want and look at whatever they want is
not true it clearly says that they have
to be denied it doesn't mean that they
were allowed but there were certain
thank you
and i'm the one that talked about public
spaces i i don't
want to think that a school board member
has to go through
to get a public or make a request to get
information
but i think this is a this is a bill
that's looking for a problem and there
have been problems where people go in
and are denied for some reason by the
superintendent
in my understanding based on the
testimony i heard by the observation of
my wife who was a school board member
for eight years by
talks with other people that are school
board members i think that if i were a
school board member and i was denied
access to information that i needed
and i went and asked for it and maybe
the superintendent didn't like the way i
asked for it and said you are now barred
from the school
i believe that school boards act as
units a lot of them have protocol like
they do in nashua that says the sq
that
that prohibit
school board members from going in
individually and dealing with employees
because school boards act as a unit so
if i were that person who couldn't get
that information i would go back to the
school board if i was not the president
i would complain to the president of the
school board and that unit as a school
board should take action against that
superintendent for doing whatever it is
they did
and get the information that the school
board needs
so that's how i would handle that
this time we'll move the question
if you are in support of adopting
[Music]
please say yay if you are opposed please
say nay
the clerk will not call the roll
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
yes
representative bert yes
representative pearson yes
representative greene yes clark votes
yes representative berry yes
representative true
yes
representative pratt yes
representative marston yes
representative harriet gathright no
representative sue newman
no representative o'hearn
no
representative bordenay
representative muse
no
representative ray newman
representative heath
representative
conley no
representative laflem
no
representative hamlet
chairman abbas
chair votes yes
11 yays 10 nays
the amendment is adopted
representative walsh you wish to be
recognized to make a motion of ought to
pass as amended
so moved
second that has been seconded by
representative roy
at this time we'll now move move the
question uh the motion is ought to pass
as amended
the clerk will now call the roll
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
yes
representative burt yes representative
pearson
yes representative greene yes
clerk votes yes representative berry yes
representative true
yes representative pratt
yes representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright no
representative
who's in for laura
sue newman
no
representative o'hearn no
representative bourdain no
representative muse no
representative ray newman
no
representative heath
representative conley
no
representative leflam
no representative hamblet
no
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
11 years ten nays
representative should prepare the
representative ray newman will be we'll
i'm always happy when you try to help me
out
this time we'll now close the executive
session on house bill 10
10.72
yes
at this time we'll now open the
executive session
on house bill 1348 that's relative to
the legalization of a certain amount of
cannabis
send the chair recognizes representative
roy to make a motion
thank you mr chairman i would move um
interim study on the spell
we already have uh several
is there a second
sorry that motion has been seconded by
representative welch
representative roy you may speak to your
motion um as i was saying we already
have um several bills before the full
house regarding cannabis
um
and
adding more to that mix um is not
helpful i feel like we have two distinct
choices right now before the body um so
this bill is not necessary therefore i
at this time we'll now move the question
if you're in support of the motion of
interim study
of house bill 1348
please say yay if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk will not call
the roll vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
yes
representative burt
representative pearson
yes representative greene yes clark
votes yes representative berry yes
representative true yes
representative pratt yes
representative marston
yes
representative harriet catherine
representative sue newman
no
representative o'hearn
yes
representative bordnay yes
representative muse no
representative ray newman
yes
representative heath
representative conley
yes
representative of lamb yes
representative hamblet
no
jammin abbas
the chair votes yes
would there be a minority report
yes
representative muse will be preparing
representative
representative roy will be preparing the
majority report
this time we'll now close the executive
at this time we'll now open the
executive session on house bill 1306
relative to personal possession of
marijuana
representative roy you must be
recognized
i do i would like to make a motion of an
interim study
the motion has been seconded by
representative welch
roy wish to speak to your motion
i do i would um reiterate what i said in
my previous statement that um this
this committee has passed several
cannabis bills on to the full house for
consideration by the body we have
one allowing unfettered access to
marijuana and another one that would set
up a system of sales controlled by the
state
for the body to consider
having those two pieces of legislation
currently before the body this would be
unnecessary and therefore a move that we
representative conley thank you quickly
this also you know regardless of how one
feels about legalization and the other
bills that have moved before this
committee this one would allow 18 year
olds to possess and use this substance
which is not aligned with other bills
which have set it at 21 so that's
well said the biggest problem with
this committee we had
i want to say nine cannabis bills
they they conflict and a lot of them are
amending or changing the same rsa so
even if you support a recreational
policy
these all can't go over the finish line
because one would supersede the next so
there is something to say about picking
one
we apparently picked two
but
picking a third i just don't i don't see
we're just passing it to pass it and
trying to make a point but i think
we put out two different policies and
maybe we just see what those the fate of
those policies are representative newman
i just have a parliamentary inquiry
you're so recognized
thank you let's say out of this plethora
of bills that we have
several of them were passed
and then they went to the uh for to the
session
and they were all passed
what would be the result of that
situation
depending on which bill some of them are
second committee bills so some of those
would be assigned to another committee
uh the ones who are not would go on
would advance to the
other body the one that we are not
allowed to say the name of
i'm in support of changing the house
rule so we can just say their name but
that's just me anyway if they were all
pass
in the other body without it being
amended so they wouldn't come back to
the house
they would then move on to uh
to the
corner office for potential signature
which it could be a red signature blue
signature or not signed at all
but if two or three of them were to
become law
the last one to become law would
supersede the two ones that would have
become law before it
thank you
this time we'll now move the question uh
if you're in support of the motion of
interim study
please say yay if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk will not call
the role
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch yes
representative burt yes representative
pearson yes
representative greene yes
clerk votes yes representative berry yes
representative true yay
representative pratt yes and
representative marston
yay
representative harriet gathright no
representative sue newman
no
representative o'hearn
yes
representative bordenay yes
representative muse
yes
representative ray newman
representative heath
representative connolly yes
representative laflamme yes
representative hamlet
no
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
representative roy you wish to move for
consent i do
there's an objection by representative
harrygath
representative harry catherine will be
preparing the minority report
this time we'll now close the executive
session
representative conley
in respect to house bill
1127 is there any amendment or any
anything being done with that
mr chairman that's been a vexing
uh endeavor i think for multiple members
of this committee of how to
get this to a place that we i think we
all want to be
there
is a prohibition in the house of turning
a bill into a resolution
which has been described by ols and the
clerk as
probably what we want to do but we can't
do it
so the short answer is uh
we don't have anything coming on that
bill
thank you
at this time we'll now open the
this time the chair recognizes
i would like to make a motion of being
expedient to legislate
that motion was seconded by
representative
wallace
this bill was very well intended
annulments of convictions for
people who've passed away and although
extremely well intended the optics of
that could be rather difficult
especially
if we're dealing with the conviction
it's over 100 years old
you need to have standing to file the
paperwork for an annulment however
justified the
request may be
for example could i just walk into a
courthouse and file
a petition for an annulment for someone
i'm not related to i'm not
i'm not the next of kin i'm not i'm not
appointed by the court as the minister
of the estate
that can get that can get complicated in
of
itself i i think what we wanted to do
here is that it involves what
i think we
based on the committee's discussion
appeared to be an unjust conviction for
someone that was involved uh
convicted of witchcraft
so
we agreed in modern time that that was
not appropriate and that was unjustified
however
for the is it appropriate for the
legislator to
either vacate that conviction or grant
an annulment of that conviction through
an act of legislation what we could do
is allow for an annulment and then
someone would have to go into the court
to do it
how do you how does that happen for
someone who's uh
who's already passed away
if if the person wants to go in right
now if you have a conviction we passed
a nullman bill's last term relating to
possession of cannabis under three
quarters an ounce or less
any person can go into the court and
they can imply to from the annulment
that's how it would work
what do you do if it's 200 years old i
don't i don't know i couldn't figure out
an answer to that
uh we were
we tried in good faith to at least
amend this to a proclamation and uh we
unfortunately the rules do not print us
to do that so
we're saying it here right now
and that's the best we can that's the
best we can do and thanks for no one
making a point of order from me doing
that
representative roy i would i would agree
with with the chair and i would also
point out that the governor has the
preliminary power to grant pardons um
posthumously if so necessary um so if if
there were a case to be made to have
someone
have their conviction pardoned or
reversed or nulled the governor does
have that power
um so the legislation and that's
exclusive to the executive for a reason
so i don't think it's appropriate for
the legislature to be reaching in and
interfering in um previous judicial
rulings where that power and the
constitution was specifically allocated
to the chief executive thank you
and
just to clarify what the bill did it
identified a specific individual who
would be whose conviction would would uh
be annulled which that was the other
problem is that it's one
thing to have a blanket annulment a
policy for anyone convicted of said
offense but to identify an individual
on you know by name
we're not we weren't clear that that was
something within the
authority of the legislator
representative boarding
thank you mr chair
uh
though it is clear that this bill has
some
issues
and
but
we just heard two other bills that we
put on interim study and i think that
that would probably be a more
appropriate motion
for this bill because putting an as a
in expedient legislate
basically says that we don't value there
is anything important in this bill at
all
so i will have to vote against the itl
and prefer another motion come forward
representative boarding if i may inquire
hypothetically if the motion of index
being to legislate was withdrawn
would you would the member be inclined
to make a motion for an interim study
representative rory
um i i agree with representative
bourdain that the topic itself is
is a worthy topic for discussion and
um so i will withdraw my bill in
consideration of a pending uh motion for
interim study
second withdrawn as well
yes
representative bourdain you wish to be
recognized to make a motion of interim
study
yes mr chair i do make a promotion to
interim study bill uh
1127.
is there a second
it's been seconded by representative
i would like to point out that this is
the second legislative session where
we've considered this bill
we actually voted on an identical bill
uh in 2020 uh hb 1127 which passed this
committee unanimously and went to
consent
and then was killed by covet
we've had plenty of time to consider
this
what this bill does
isn't just grant annulments to two
individuals but it sets up a legislative
process
the legislature has in its power in to
grant an element um
uh and we know that because uh in 2021
one of the things that we did was we
annulled uh all of the convictions of
people
uh who uh were penalized for violating
the governor's coveted executive orders
so this is something we definitely have
the power to do
and in the case of these two individuals
what we'd be doing is we'd be cr we'd
basically be correcting a real injustice
so we can't go back to the nineteen
fifties we can't go back two hundred
years and change the things that happen
to those people but what we do have the
power to do is to change how those
people are remembered in history and how
they're remembered on our books that's
really what this bill does
it also establishes a process that can
be used if there are other people
that this legislation might apply to and
my guess is
as with these two cases
it would be applied extremely rarely
it's not easy to get a bill through to
do something like this but i'll give you
one example of another person who might
come under this
is ruth blay from portsmouth
ruth blay
either
miscarried a child
or delivered a child who was stillborn
she didn't report it to the authorities
at the time that was a capital crime and
she was actually hung in south street
cemetery um about uh about a half a mile
from where i live right now
so i mean we we have things like this
that are scattered throughout our
history
um and and i think part of our role kind
of looking back on these things
sometimes in modern times
is to say is to acknowledge the fact
that
you know there have been times in our
past when we've made mistakes and while
we don't have an opportunity to correct
the mistakes themselves we do have an
opportunity
to to correct the ledger and that's
really what this bill does in a very
articulate and effective way
i can't support the interim study
i would like to
hopefully
if we can defeat the interim study
motion
recommend this bill ought to pass thank
you
i am now very confused about the
authority of the legislature to
grant annulments
in my confusion
arises because it seems as though
if we have already
heard testimony that said we've already
passed annulments
it seems that this
legislature can can pass a bill that
grants an annulment when they like it
and not pass the
a bill when they
don't have a really keen interest in it
that may be incorrect but that is the
impression i've gotten from the
just to clarify an annulment
is granted by the court the legislator
can
impose a procedure or process for one to
be eligible or to obtain the annulment
in respect to the bill we had last year
the difference with that
the difference with that is that that
was a penalty that was not was
established through an executive order
for violating an executive order but so
was the penalty
it wasn't something that was in
uh in law
existing law that that's where that that
that's the difference between the two
thank you and there was some ques there
was a constitutional question to that as
representative roy
thank you i would just like to address
the um
the issue of uh correcting the ledger
as was stated
um i think that it's not necessarily the
job of the legislature to go back and
rewrite history i think there's value in
knowing the wrongs that were done and
seeing them and letting them stand as an
example to future generations
to see and learn from
um someone convicted of witchcraft or or
someone who was hung
for for something as the member stated
um
while at the time um in in currently
that's wrong and horrific
we can learn from that and by going back
and erasing our mistakes
i feel like that's that's uh it's not
it's doing a disservice to the children
of the future
i believe that history is what it is um
good bad
ugly
and we should learn from it not try to
erase it and change it thank you
representative boardney
thank you mr chairman
um
i was one of the people that voted all
to pass
but i have found every time that i come
here have a a bill that's heard before
the public
sometimes information comes forward that
makes you change your mind on what you
had initially uh
thought was the right thing to do
and
in the testimony on this bill we heard
there were issues with
the what
what we were trying to do
forget about what we did in the past
because we have new information
and
uh
put this as interim study
and this time we'll now move the
question if you're in support of the
motion of interim study
please say
yay if you were opposed please say nay
the clerk will not call the roll
vice chairman roy yes representative
welch yes
representative burt yes representative
pearson
yes
representative greene
no
clerk votes yes
representative berry yes
representative true
yes
representative pratt yes representative
marston
no
representative harriet gathright
representative sue newman
no
representative o'hearn yes
representative bourdain yes
representative muse
no
representative ray newman
representative conley
yes
representative laflam yes
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
representative green will will there be
a
from some youtube prepare minority
report
representative boardnet you've prepared
just
just so everyone can be ready we're the
next executive session will be hb uh
one zero zero four we're just passing
out the amendment and i'll give everyone
a minute or two to
review it
at this time we'll now open the
executive session on house bill 1004
relative to penalties for the failure to
provide information after an animal
injury
at this time the chair recognizes uh
representative rory
thank you mr chairman i would like to
make a motion of um
ought to pass as amended and offer
amendment number two zero two two zero
three six
two
h
representative roy you wish to speak to
the motion
i do um
what what the the amendment does is it
the original bill um there were concerns
about making someone stay in a situation
that was potentially
potentially
dangerous um with
heated emotions
especially if it's a juvenile or a woman
walking her dog that ends up biting
somebody
um making her stay there in other words
if someone approaches a woman jogging
with her dog and the dog bites the
person who tried to approach the woman
the bill would have made the woman have
to stay there and actually give him her
phone number that some seemed a little
bit counter-intuitive so what the the
bill would do is would it just require
that a person make themselves known to
the police and give their information to
that their dog had bit someone so that
the police know who it was and who owned
the dog and then they can verify their
rabies information and such
so that's what the amendment does it
just gives them an opportunity to to get
out of that that scene and go to the
police and make a report versus having
to give the person who was involved
representative marston
thank you mr chairman
i i basically have a question
to what representative roy just said
what would prevent anybody from leaving
representative roy you wish to answer
that or respond to that question um
the law
that's what the law is designed to do
they can leave the scene without
reporting but they have to go to the
police department and make the report if
they do not make themselves known or go
to the police with the information they
representative conley
thank you
this this bill is makes sense i guess
i'm wondering if there's like a piece
that we're not considering is if i'm in
an incident with a stranger
then there's some sort of dog bite that
occurs
and i or the owner of the dog departs
the scene without sharing information
how are police gonna find
this pr i don't is that stipulated here
i don't know if i see that but how would
one know how to find that person if no
one's giving information and the dog
bite doesn't result in any sort of
public
disposition
it's the police my understanding is that
if because this would be a crime that
they would investigate
that i mean if someone is at a dog park
and they get in their car
if the dog can be it could be a dog
that's
recognized in the neighborhood
so
you might
quite often when there's animal attacks
the the person who is injured by the
animal may know the dog's owner already
the big thing here is trying to get the
information be
about the animal if someone is attacked
by an animal
the medical recommendation is is to
confirm what that animal has updated on
their rabies shots and if they're not
the recommendation is to go get
the i don't know if it's a vac what you
want to call it but the rabies shot
we'll call it to avoid the transmission
now
i i hear that that is a very painful
procedure and it can all be avoided
if you're able to verify the status of
the animal
so i don't think that's asking too much
in addition to saving the medical
expense of having to go to the emergency
room for a painful procedure
i i don't think that's asking much
uh it's your people are responsible for
what their
animals do
for better or worse so i think this is a
good
policy it's not limited to just dogs it
doesn't apply whether the dog's on the
leash off the leash it it really offers
protection to the person the receiving
end
and i think that this is a good a good
policy
representative roy i i just wanted to
make a point that it's the same kind of
thing with leaving the scene of an
accident i mean if you get an accident
and you get your car and take off how
would the police if they didn't get the
plate no well that's i guess that's your
job they could investigate and figure it
out
so it's really
in my mind it's the same situation of
leaving the scene of an accident leaving
the scene of a dog bite i mean if your
dog bites somebody and you take off and
don't don't make your name known to the
police or to the person who was bitten
you'd be guilty of this violation
thank you
representative burt
i'm going to vote against this and the
reason is because the dog groups do not
support this
and they listed all the issues that
could come from this
um
and also
if you could you know if somebody could
answer the question you know even though
i'm voting against it i was just looking
here i don't see a time frame
so let's say somebody's dog bites
somebody is there a time frame where
they have to
tell the police or can they come in six
months and tell the police you know i
just don't see a time frame
the the amendment as proposed on line 13
says
they must report to the police
immediately
so
representative muse
one of the things i wanted to say is i'm
i'm sympathetic with the intent of this
bill um i'm a dog owner and a lot of
times in the woods you run into people
who just simply don't have their dogs
under control so i mean this is not a
an uncommon an uncommon issue but where
i'm a little stuck with this bill
is
whether it's actually doing anything
that improves on the current situation
so in a situation like that you know
like this currently
um the vast majority of dog owners
are going to stop
um
if they're if there's injury or damage
to property
they will exchange information what i'm
what i'm not sure of is is exactly
how this actually gets us to a point
where
we have
police intervening successfully in more
reportable interactions
so what i
you know a big missing thing is
where
i'm not sure what incentive there is for
somebody who has um
a dog that attacks somebody else or that
damages property uh to kind of
proactively turn themselves into the
police i know i know we we spent a long
time um
last week debating the purple paint bill
um
and enforceability was one of the main
reasons why
um
why the committee as a whole
turned
thumbs down on that one and i just don't
see
how this
is really enforceable and you know
number one and and also
how it actually
measurably improves the the current
situation over over what we have now so
i'm i'm a little stuck when it comes to
under existing law today
and i know representatives you would
never do this but if your dog
bit me and i didn't know who you were
you're under no legal obligation to
share your information
about yourself or the dog for that
matter and that actually did occur
and that's what that was the inspiration
for at least the underlying bill
i believe the amendment whether you
support the underlying bill or even the
amendment i believe is a better version
of what the
it is an improvement i
so i would
encourage support supporting the
amendment but district the idea is of
having a penalty is to deter the
behavior
and that's
if there is no penalty for it
we have different we have felonies we
have misdemeanors we have fines or
violations the idea is to deter conduct
and there's only so much we can do
but
in some situations i believe people will
comply with the law knowing that it's a
law especially in the sich that
situation that happened and where from
what i understand the police were
present but they could still could not
get that person to
identify themselves
because there was no law so in that
place enforce in that situation
enforceability well if there was a
misdemeanor offense
they
i don't want to speak for what the
police would have done but i can imagine
they would have at least raised this
mention this to that person and gave
them the option to perhaps reconsider
their conduct
so there is is it going to they're going
to be situations where someone gets away
with an offense
unfortunately that happens with a lot of
offenses including
perhaps this one as well so
so i i didn't say i was unsympathetic to
the goal of the bill i'm very
sympathetic to the goal of the bill my
issue is just on the process itself
um
i i'm just not sure that this is
in and
i i think i'm agreeing with uh with
representative byrd
um there were a lot of issues that were
pointed out that weren't um
that weren't i know
nobody stopped clutching your chest
everybody
but there are um but but i do think that
there are a lot of there are a lot of
issues and a lot of steps a lot of eyes
and tees that weren't dotted and crossed
in this particular amendment or bill
that really need to be addressed before
this is ready for prime time
so as much as i would love to pass a
bill like this
i just don't think this is the bill to
pass
thank you
i've read the sentence that i think
begins on line 10 and goes on for
several lines
several times and i'm having a hard time
trying to figure out what that requires
certain people to do and report to the
police it's just to me
the amendment may be better but i i
and i may vote for the amendment but i
don't think i think i'm going to agree
with representative muse and bert
representative bourdain
second mr chairman
um i remember that angela ferrari
presented us with a list of issues with
uh this particular bill from dog owners
um
and since i just got this amendment
today i've not had a chance to uh go
back and see if all her her concerns
were addressed in the amendment
so i'm having problems i understand the
intent of the bill and the amendment but
not sure we're there yet
if we would like to
recess this executive
session
and come back at a later time when we
can assure ourselves that all the
concerns have been addressed i'd be
willing to to go that way
thanks
representative
thank you
the concerns not with that have just
been articulated notwithstanding i don't
like that we don't make clear that this
should not be a jailable offense so
i think
if we're gonna go down the route of
maybe pausing this for a bit
making clear that this is a class b
misdemeanor no jail time
especially because if we talk about what
we learned again with the purple paint
bill as people might not know this
change has taken effect for many years
making someone subject to
however unlikely jail time for this
so representative calling if i
understand you correctly if when when it
just says misdemeanor which my
understanding would give the
the
prosecutor the discretion to prosecute
as a class a or class b if it
expressly stated class b misdemeanor you
would be in support
of the the amendment
mr chairman certainly more palatable but
i we would have to wait and see what the
amendment looked like
if that was the only change
it's just word for word identical all it
says is class b misdemeanor would that
would you support that amendment that
would assuage many of my concerns yes
would you vote yay or nay
mr chairman
representative true
thank you mr chair
from my notes uh when we heard uh
testimony on this
this is a bill that came about because
of a
singular incident
and
i think we have problems
when we try to address a singular
on my notes
the police were called in this
particular situation
and the information was gathered and
exchanged
i guess that's the way it should be
handled if people have a problem with
some dog
viciously attacking them or or their
property
then you call the police
i don't see any value to to passing this
we'll see we'll see how this goes and we
may we may have to
make some accommodations
if you're in support of adopting
amendment
2022-0362h
please say yay if you oppose please say
nay the clerk would not call the roll
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
representative burt
no
representative pearson
yes
representative green yes
clerk votes yes representative berry yes
representative true
nay
representative pratt yes
no
representative harriet gathright
representative sue newman
no
representative o'hearn
representative bordenay
yes
representative ray newman
no
representative heath
representative conley no
representative leflam no
representative hamlet
no
chairman abbas
chair votes yes
nine yays 12 nays
the adoption of the amendment fails
well there you have it
representative colony even if you were
to reconsider your your vote
the set amendment would still be short
by one vote if i may inquire for anyone
who did not support
adopting them would changing the
misdemeanor language to express the
state class be misdemeanor
change anyone or influence anyone's
decision
then
there you have it
do you wish to you wish to withdraw your
well you but it's still an a not to pass
motion that is
as as
a would you wish to withdraw the ought
represent
representative muse
that's been second representative
gathering do you wish to speak to your
i apologize i think we've had enough
conversation about that though
representative burt
i see the attempt
of this bill
you know and i understand why it was
brought forward
so i don't think the bill
intent was was bad it's just the way
it's written
will not work and with the
dog groups not supporting it
i will be supporting the itl
at this time we will now move the
question if you're in support of the
motion of inexplaining to legislate
please say yay if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk will not call
the roll
vice chairman roy
no
representative welch
yes
representative burt
representative greene
no
clerk votes yes
representative berry
no
yay representative pratt
representative marston
yay
representative harriet gathright
representative sue newman yes
representative o'hearn yes
representative bourdain yes
representative muse yes representative
ray newman
yes representative heath
representative conley
yes
representative laflamme yes
representative hamlet yes
chairman abbas
with 15 yays
five nays
fifty fifteen to six
representative parrot catholic will you
prepare the majority report
this time we'll now close the executive
just for a point of clarification hb
1539 was noticed for a
i'm fairly confident that i probably
advise the
committee
assistant to help schedule that however
we already exact that bill
so
hp 1539 okay
that we did that back in january so i
apologize for to the public for that
confusion but
i'm going to simply open the executive
session then reclose it if just a as a
sake of
procedural representative boarding you
recognized him ah thank you i
agree that we have executive bill
however if we look at the docket for the
bill it is not
recorded that we executed the bill in
fact it's
recorded that we are
executing it today
so
somehow that information was misplaced
or never got to the clerk
so so when a bill once we
have a vote on in an executive session
bear with me one moment
certainly
so once an executive session is
the clerk
of the committee will hold on to the
bill
once it's delivered to the house clerk
that's when the bill officially leaves
the committee but once the bill until
the bill officially leaves the committee
the committee is free to
reopen the executive session and
reconsider any anything that was done
i'm going to open it and just merely
close it
because we've already voted on it and
i'm not inclined to recognize anyone for
reconsideration but it is scheduled for
today so for the sake of
calendar purposes i think it'd be
appropriate to
open and then close
i guess it's a procedural question
so why are we opening it we've already
done it
it's been notified
i'll be honest i'm going to open it
the executive session for about two
seconds and then close it i just wanted
it is notice for a hearing today so i
feel it's appropriate to just
open and close it so it's not kind of
hanging in the wind because technically
if let's say
some people left the room i could reopen
it then we could actually
reconsider it if
suppose i was one of the seven that
didn't want it
in explain to legislate so i think it's
appropriate for the members present and
for the public here to
just
get clean up clean up the notice here
and
cancel each one out one by one so
that's i'm not sure i'm required to do
that but i think it's in the it's just
for transparency purposes let's just do
it
representative newman
just for the information of the chair
i wrote the um
minority report for this bill there was
mention of an amendment there is no
amendment forthcoming and so i agree
with the what the chair is attempting to
do so
at this time we will now open the
executive session house bill 1539
relative to the removal of certain
information from the new hampshire state
police website
and this time we'll now
close the executive session house bill
15-39
question for the chair
representative marston you're recognized
thank you why was the
bill
1539 held by the i'm assuming the
secretary in the office
was it an oversight or was it for a
it wasn't held
i'm going to be honest i didn't inquire
i i'm pretty sure i
gave a list of everything to notice and
perhaps through my own oversight
trying not to throw myself under the bus
no problem you're forgiven
and this time we'll now open the
executive session
on
house bill 1215 relative to the
definition of residual amount in the
representative roy you you're so
recognized
thank you um i'd like to make a motion
that's been seconded by representative
wallace
representative roy you recognize to
speak on your motion thank you
um i understand what the sponsor was
trying to do but the this this bill as
written um even with an amendment that
was proposed
would um it has far-reaching effects the
original bill as written would have made
it would have made it a uh
what is an infraction
a residual amount
so a gram of fentanyl could kill
everybody in this room several times
um so we we certainly don't want to be
in the business of
making that a residual amount
furthermore even if you took the
fentanyl out of it
the effect it would have on the existing
statutory scheme where we have
certain penalties for certain amounts of
certain classes of controlled substances
it would throw that into chaos for
example cocaine has a certain amount of
um
for for a gram of cocaine you could get
up to i believe it was 15 years
this could turn it into a residual
amount so it would affect all the entire
statutory scheme that's currently in
place with regard to controlled
substances and amounts
um if those need adjusting then that's
worthy of debate but a one piece bill
that says all these things are suddenly
residual amounts would throw our current
uh statutory scheme in the chaos
um
so this this bill the intention is great
but it's it's not nearly ready for us to
representative conley thank you
representative roy does
specifically with the fentanyl make a
good point however this committee and i
believe
this committee in past terms has really
struggled with how to
address
small quantities of drugs and the
punishment for that we've we passed a
bill last year
that would have done that that ran into
challenges in the other body but the way
the current statue is written it's like
a frankenstein monster of so trying to
decouple
the quantities and punishments uh
without
allowing drug dealers to get off as well
is hard to do and
this addresses that and i wonder if it
could
by fixing the fentanyl point maybe
maybe get through and it's also worth
noting this was proposed
and supported not by
or by a county attorney who uh asked for
this so
i do think there's merit here
representative rory
i i agree um but the cocaine point is
also a question i mean it says a gram of
cocaine or less would be a residual
amount but the other statute has
significant jail time for it
so we would we would set up conflicts in
all the statutes if we're going to do
this we need to do a right and address
each and every statute i just don't
think we can do it with one bill that
would just cause conflicts across it i i
agree with my my friend
but i just don't think this piece of
legislation is is
i think the clear for clarification is
that one gram of a substance depending
on the substance is very different
so perhaps
going by a measurement or weight is not
not necessarily
how this should be approached
and
we can we can do
comparisons all day on
on that subject but
one gram of fentanyl is elite can be a
lethal amount so why would that be
considered a residual amount
so i think what we're trying to do here
is
and not forget about the opioid issue
that's going on in the state so
if anyone has any comments
at this time we can
representative marston
thank you mr chairman
if if i'm not mistaken
the
prime sponsor of this bill did not show
up for the hearing and at some point he
kind of gave an indication that he
wanted to withdraw it which couldn't
happen but
i don't i don't believe that was that
was this this bill
i think
that may have been hb1025
and this time
you can now move the question if you're
in support of the motion of the nxp
legislative hospital 1215 please say yay
if you are opposed
please say nay the clerk would not call
the role
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch yes representative
bert
yes
representative pearson yes
representative greene yes
clerk votes yes representative barry yes
representative true
representative pratt yes representative
marston
yay
representative harriet gathright yes
representative sue newman
yes
representative o'hearn
representative bordenay yes
representative muse yes
representative ray newman
representative heath
representative connolly yes
representative of lamb yes
representative hamlet
yes
and chairman abbas the chair votes yes
yay 21 yays
consent
some moves
minority report
sorry
that's good
foreign
representative harry garth wright and
representative board name uh in respect
to house bill
i know there is a subcommittee hearing
that's scheduled on friday
uh it was supposed to be last friday but
i feel like every time we schedule a
subcommittee we get
a snowstorm over a foot of snow so
would that
i'm not the one scheduling but
there is there is two different
amendments that have been
prepared
representative welch has reviewed them
and they are
is there any work that the subcommittee
needs wishes to
accomplish or discuss or do
do you believe that that amendment's
ready to be
discussed by the committee as a whole
i'm a member of the subcommittee and i
so what we'll do is we'll make sure
everyone on that subcommittee has a copy
of the amendment right the whole all the
members will have a copy maybe review it
when we break for launch
and see if
and the committee will be in recess to
11 11
45.
oh
if the members of the committee can take
at this time we will now open the
executive session on house bill
1266.
relative to restrictions on enforcement
of federal immigration laws
this time the chair recognizes
representative roy to make a motion
i move hb 1266 off to pass his amendment
as amended and i offer amendment number
zero nine one four h as in hotel
that has been
representative rory wish to speak to
your motion i do thank you mr chairman
what this bill does
this bill prohibits
any
the state or any subdivision of the
state for making a law or policy
that would prohibit
law enforcement from cooperating with
the immigration enforcement
of the federal government for a person
who is already in custody for a
violation of state law
that means
if someone is arrested
on any
state law violation be it oui domestic
violence what what have you
and they book that person
and it pops up there's an ice detainer
on that person
the police are not
prohibited
from cooperating and notifying ice
this does not mandate that police
cooperate and contact ice this just says
that the town or municipality or the
department cannot have a policy that
um
and i think that that basically it's
it's all it does is prevent
any
policy that says that we're not going to
cooperate with immigration
it leaves it where it belongs in the
hands of the police department
and only again i repeat only
affects someone who's been arrested for
a violation of state law this does not
allow new hampshire law enforcement to
go around enforcing or questioning
people's immigration status or harass
anybody
all it means is if someone gets arrested
on something else and during the booking
process
ice detainer pops up in the system
they are able to cooperate and contact
immigration
representative bourdain
thank you mr chairman
um
comparing this amendment to the original
bill
it changes the flavor almost completely
but i have to wonder
what is the need for this bill with this
amendment
uh political order
law enforcement ready has the right to
do whatever they want as far as
enforcing uh immigration
detainment
now
if
for example county officials
did not want the sheriff's department to
enforce
our detainment of people
because they felt that
it would
affect
the
ability of law enforcement to
enter
areas that
with
people that were had immigrated from
other countries whether
legally or not
and
if
for example law enforcement
was not welcome in that area
then
that might be a problem with
becoming a crime center because
crime could proliferate where law
enforcement is not allowed
so i'm
even though i really think that the
amendment is an improvement i really
think that the bill needs to be itl
representative conley
thank you mr chairman
appreciate the effort that the vice
chair put into this amendment he and i
have discussed this
several times and i think had
fruitful
discussions um
a couple things come to mind though one
there's no penalty
so if somebody were to violate this
i don't know what happens i guess
nothing
and
for folks who would likely be affected
by this
although it's limited to being arrested
the primary way undocumented folks
encounter law enforcement is through a
motor vehicle infraction
things like an uninspected vehicle
driving without a license so forth those
typically dealt with immediately they're
not necessarily brought to the station
those are arrests
and finally just going back to what
we heard in a different debate around
firearms in the state when the committee
voted to do exactly the opposite of what
the broader intent of this bill would do
is
again quoting alan rice one of the more
conservative people in our state
state police enforce state laws
federal police enforce federal laws
if it's good enough for one part of the
law it should be good enough for the
rory
thank you mr chairman and i i thank the
um the gentleman for his uh kind of
remarks on regarding our cooperation on
the
uh spirit of the bill i i would simply
point out that
this does not
authorize
state or local law enforcement to quote
unquote enforce federal law
all it does again
this is after they've been arrested and
they've been brought to the police
station and they are being booked
and their information is entered into
the leap system
and a detainer pops up from ice
they are not
prohibited from contacting ice by a
local
subdivision of the state
for example if a town
says we are a sanctuary city for
undocumented immigrants
they cannot prohibit the police
department if someone's under arrest
from honoring the ice detainer they're
not enforcing the law all they're saying
is okay we will contact ice and hold
them until they come and get them
it doesn't mandate that they do that it
just says they cannot be prohibited from
doing that by a a political body um
there's a distinct difference between
the firearms issue where we said
we didn't want
local and state law enforcement from
going out and enforcing federal law i.e
arresting people for violations of
federal law
versus someone who's already been
arrested
and there's
a warrant if you will a detainer
saying that the federal government would
like to see these people and speak to
them because they missed a court date or
what have you
um so they're they're apples and oranges
um and again with regard to the penalty
it's difficult to assign a criminal
penalty to a municipality
the fact that the law says you shall not
do it um
in and of itself i mean we are a nation
of laws
and
to to to have someone or a municipality
just flout the law if they do that then
we may have to readdress it but at this
point i think just saying that you can't
do it should be enough
that government agencies
not consciously violate the law thank
you
according to the way that i look at this
bill and read the words that are on the
paper
it says the law shall not adopt or
enforce any law or policy
and then it gives a bunch of qualifiers
from cooperating that prohibits
those people from cooperating
with the enforcement of the federal
immigration laws
and we're saying that that doesn't that
doesn't make them have to do that
but when
a police department or anybody who is
enforcing laws as i understand it
they don't enforce laws all the time
so
what i'm seeing here is they can't even
write a policy so if they determine that
was the appropriate thing because they
were
putting their resources to to enforcing
other laws
they could not write a policy that would
tell the people who enforce the laws
that
there are certain laws that shouldn't be
enforced like the speed limit there are
policies i assume they know 50 miles
over or whatever
they could have that policy anymore so
then what
representative harry garth
thank you mr chair um when i read this
at first i thought this was a
good amendment um but the more i look
into it
um it's really not doing anything
because if you remember the original
bill
wanted to enforce us to to to respond
okay to federal laws
all right so now this one says you have
a choice they have a choice today
in every city and every town
that we have here
so for me um
it's not necessary to have this
we should be itl in that original bill
that was horrible we had we heard a lot
of testimony that day
a lot of
testimony and i feel that for us to try
to i don't know i don't even i really
don't understand what this is doing
but there's already policies in place
that
law enforcement has to do when it comes
to
those that are on the list
or have a detainer
that's already in place so what are we
doing here
representative representative muse you
recognized there's a couple points um
one is that uh this bill is yet another
attack on local control uh in new
hampshire
they're not every community has large
minority populations but mine does and
uh nashua does and
manchester does um
another thing that i i just like to
remind people and this was actually
pointed out in the written testimony of
the american civil liberties union not
sure if it was actually pointed out in
the in the oral testimony
but i'll read it to you
unlike criminal warrants which are
supported by a judicial determination of
probable cause ice detainers are issued
by ice enforcement agents themselves
without any authorization or oversight
by a judge or other neutral decision
maker
it's well settled in law that a person's
presence in the united states in
violation of immigration laws standing
alone is not a crime
so you know what we're what we're not
doing here is we're not
uh
we're basically not making it impossible
for federal agents to enforce enforce
the law
basically because an immigration
detainer according to the way that i
read this is a civil issue and not a
matter of criminal law
so with that in mind
i'm going to vote against the amendment
and vote against the bill thank you
representative roy
thank you
it is well said a law that the first
time you went to the united states
illegally it is not a criminal offense
however the second time in subsequent
times are criminal offenses
also failing to appear in court after
being released after being detained upon
entry is also a crime but that
notwithstanding we're not asking anyone
to allocate resources we're not asking
anyone to to go out of their way
all we're saying is if someone has
already been arrested and is in a
holding cell in our state and there's a
detainer from ice
that they not be prohibited from
contacting ice we're not even mandating
they do it
with regard to the question of why are
we doing this there are several
municipalities within the state that
have passed policies
political bodies not law enforcement
political parties that have said
they do not want to cooperate with
immigration
so that's the reason we're doing this
and as far as the question of whether or
not you know ice can issue these on the
zone that authority was delegated to
them by the united states congress
through
law they didn't just make it up on their
own so for us to sit here and laugh at
it and flout it and say well you know it
doesn't matter and they can do this on
their own this is this is law in this
body specifically this body
is to look at criminal law and public
safety
and it is a violation of law
to just ignore federal law
and to just release people into the
public who have
been requested to be held by immigration
enforcement
and just ignore it um so in response to
all of those things that those those
arguments are are without merit and
again this does not mandate or allocate
resources it's only if someone's been
arrested already for violating our laws
just for a point of
clarification here
a lot of the testimony we heard was
about
allowing police officers and law
enforcement divisions to exercise their
i believe the amendment
took that into consideration
it allows on a case-by-case basis for a
law enforcement agency to decide
what they want to do in that particular
circumstance it's not mandating they do
one
take one action or another and
how that discretion is exercised for
better or worse is would
would be something that the that law
enforcement agency would have to answer
on to to universally prohibit um
any type of discretion to be used on
whether or not to
um
assist or cooperate with the detainer
request in respect to someone who's
already in the custody of law
enforcement this is not authorizing
police to go out
in
and take people into custody
because there's a detainer request this
is someone who's already in the custody
of the state
county or the
county sheriff's department or local law
enforcement that's what this would do
and it gives them gives that the law
enforcement
the opportunity to exercise said
discretion
that's the that's what this does it's
not forcing one one way or the other
so i i think this is a
fair compromise on the subject
and uh allows the police to use their
discretion so that's i'll be supporting
the amendment
representative bourdain
thank you mr chairman
i will point out at least one of the
communities that were identified
that nazi enforced immigration laws
was done at a town meeting
at
town meeting day
they directed their
law enforcement not to
enforce immigration laws
so
that is the will of the people
in that
area
now
this bill
as amended
would say
we don't care
you don't care that the people of this
town
do not want this to happen
you cannot make
a ordinance saying
that
law enforcement will not act in this way
against
their own wishes
and since they pay for law enforcement
in their community you would think that
they would follow the directions that
the people wanted
so i think
even one exception to
the statewide
law
is enough to disqualify the need for the
representative muse
yeah i would just like to echo uh
representative bourdain's comments um
my community decided to do this a few
years ago
it was widely supported
um
i think one of the things we need to be
very careful of is remembering that our
job isn't to uh override
uh other elected bodies especially local
elected bodies whenever we happen to
disagree with them
this is an area where the people have
made their their feelings known
some of us may or may not like it
but
but i don't think it's our job to try to
reverse policies like this and and
frankly one of the things that i haven't
heard come up yet but this this is
common what's commonly referred to as an
anti-sanctuary cities bill so let's just
say the words and get it out of the way
that's exactly what this thing is and
what it does is it takes the control out
of the hands of public officials in in
local communities to make these
decisions
do any members wish to speak on the
question that's before the committee who
at this
we're going to we're going to move the
question because the goal was to break
at this time we'll now move the question
the question is whether to adopt
if you're in support of adopting the
amendment please say yay if you were
opposed
please say nay the clerk will not call
the roll vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
yes
representative burt yes representative
pearson yes
representative greene yes
clerk votes yes representative berry yes
representative true yay representative
pratt yes representative marston
yay
representative harriet gathright no
representative sue newman no
no
representative bordenay no
representative muse
no
representative ray newman
no representative heath
no
representative conley no representative
leflam
no representative hamlet no
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
11 yays 10 nays the adopt the amendment
is adopted
representative roy you wish to make a
motion about to pass as amended
that has been seconded by representative
burt
is there any any anyone additional
comment
representative newman ray newman
thank you
if these agencies cannot even write
policy to communicate
whether they should or should not
contact ice then the department does not
this time will now move the question if
you're in support of the motion of
octopass as amended please say yay if
you're opposed
please say nade the clerk will not call
the roll vice chairman roy
absolutely
uh represented welch
yes
representative burt yes representative
pearson yes
representative greene yes rep clerk
votes yes representative berry yes
representative true yay
representative pratt yes
representative marston
ea
representative harriet gathright no
representative sue newman no
representative o'hearn
no
representative bordenay no
representative muse
no
representative ray newman
no representative heath no
representative connolly no
representative lam no
representative hamlet no
and chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
mosh about to pass has amended passes
anyone
wish to just name a member that wishes
to
anyone want to volunteer
representative colony would draft the
will it i presume there'll be a majority
report
representative roy
and this time we'll now close the
executive session on
house bill 1266
we'll be in recess
he's
you had you mentioned to me that you may
by 1246
this time we're now called call to order
the criminal justice and uh public
safety committee and we will now open
the executive session
on
house bill 1296
relative to the money coin or currency
which may be forfeited in connection
this time the chair will recognize
representative burt to make a motion
thank you mr chairman i make a motion of
that motion has been seconded by
representative wallace representative
burt you may speak to your motion all
right
this amendment
i had some talking points and sadly i
left them at home what the amendment
does is it clears up some of the issues
that we talked about in the committee
on the bill
um
what this is
oh
boy now you may you may please state
your point of order
may we know what the amendment number is
please yes thank you i forgot to mention
before i have to
we'll uh just this
in the future i wouldn't consider that
to be a valid point of view just simply
a parliamentary inquiry can you
and but i do appreciate you pointing
that to the attention of the committee
yes
representative all right thank you mr
chairman i do apologize i didn't mention
the
amendment because there's two of them
the amendment i'm looking at is
2022-08748
and like i was saying earlier what this
does the amendment the current amendment
in front of us it just clears up any of
the concerns that was brought up during
the hearing
and
you know to make sure that you know
um
you know i remember
mr mcgrath you know he spoke on this how
it's needed
and you know we've passed similar bills
like this but this one's just going to
clean up a lot of language on the
forfeiture
in connections with a drug
offense so then that way the police
and like myself i do carry cash
occasionally
you know they can confiscate that but
and at that point i would have to prove
that this money was not being used for
drug related activities where this puts
the work back to the state like it
should be to prove you are guilty
of something and that's why they have
your money
and that's pretty much what it does
representative bourdain
mr chairman um
this is uh like a 11 page
amendment
to another
11-page amendment
can we
so you mentioned in
two different amendments
you want and you want a comparison
between the two
what is the amendment number to the
other
other amendment the other amendment was
amendment
2022-0264
h
[Music]
i don't i don't have a copy of that
other
drafted amendment
to do the comparison
so i wouldn't be i wouldn't be able to
answer that if there's any member of the
committee that could respond to
representative bourdain
no one no members raised their hands to
answer the question so i do apologize
so
how are we supposed to process a 11-page
amendment when we just were handed it we
can't even read it that fast to see what
the changes were and
let's let's just try to
only speak one at a time if we don't
mind
are you raising a point of order
it appears so
and please state your point of order the
point of order is that we have been
given
a 11 page amendment with no notification
and no clarification what those changes
were
and are expected to vote on without
so i
is there a house rule or anywhere in the
mason's manual that you would suggest
that there's a rule that has been
adopted
by the house that is not being followed
i understand that perhaps the discretion
being utilized may not be
something that is
a popular decision but
discretionary decision aside is there an
actual rule not being followed
that you can reference
perhaps i misstated mr chairman
that uh porn order may not be the uh
correct
uh
question it may be
what is the other one
so if i understand you're withdrawing
your point of order but you you're
not inclined to support
the adoption this amendment given the
time frame you would have to review it
in respect to its contents
and is that yes yes sir i i'm not sure
what to do with this yet whether we
should come back at another time but i
think that to adopt this amendment
without knowing what's in it
is a regular
thank you representative
and representative burke in in fairness
to the point being raised by uh
representative bourdain
there was a prior we had a public
hearing
uh because this was this was ruled not
this amendment but it was a non-german
amendment
yes it was a non-german amendment uh so
i don't have that amendment i thought i
did and i don't
um
and that's not before us can
now i'm going to ask a parliamentary
inquiry of the committee
because this is not the exact draft of
the non-germain amendment
it's similar but it's not we permitted
to
would we be required to have another
my understanding is that any member can
bring an amendment
during an exec session and we don't have
to have a hearing on this
yes it but it would have to if it's a
non-german amendment you still would
have to have a hearing on it so what i'm
saying is we had a public hearing on a
non-german amendment this
is although similar to that
it's not word for word identical so i'm
parliamentary question that i have for
the rest of the committee
mr chair you do have a resource option
with the house clerk's office
if if you choose to exercise that as the
chair and representative pearson would
you mind
communicating that question to the house
clerk
i can communicate the question that
so let me let me do this that's for
clarification
let me inquire because i i just want to
make sure we're following the procedure
the original bill had 11 lines
this is considerably more
language than the original bill and i
think it'll take a little time to figure
out what it is unless somebody can
explain it
i understood but we had it we had a
public hearing on the non-german
amendment already
we're really just trying to figure out
because this isn't word for that
amendment
well
without being able to explain what's
different if i'm i'm assuming that even
this amendment would also be non-germane
but i want to make sure we're not
violating the house rule if not we can
so what i'm inclined to do is maybe look
into that a little further
and representative board
well that may not have been your
intention you've inspired that
thought so let me do this
i think mr chairman
on a cell phone
i think you uh requested him to talk to
mr chair
in consultation with the house clerk
because you had a public hearing on the
non-germain amendment if you choose to
amend that you do not have to hold
another public hearing and it is
permissible to amend it since there was
thank you
and representative are you able to
provide any insight on the difference
between
amendments 0 8 7 four h and represent
born the other amendment was
numbered
i don't have the other amendment in
front of me and and
to be honest once that amendment was
deemed non-germane i just moved on and
then
you know with uh representative sylvie
uh
with a lot of help from
you know
member you know from the questions that
came out of that here and
uh came up with this amendment
representative board name
chair
all right in that case since we don't
know what's in this amendment and what
the differences are
i'm going to oppose the adoption of the
amendment
and the other members wish to speak to
representative muse
yes
thank you mr chair um
i mean just
looking at this and i haven't had the
time to uh to soak it all in either
but you know we're talking about a
an 11-page or 12-page amendment that
actually
replaces a half-page original bill
this is what we used to call a trojan
horse
this is a
it's very hard very difficult to tell
how close to the original build this was
how close it is to the non-germain
amendment um picking through a few
things
uh
i was able to see uh that i know uh
richard head from the judicial system
when he testified in front of us had a
lot of concerns
about
the additional number of hearings that
this bill would require around
forfeiture
and whether or not at a time when our
court system is already overburdened
that's something that we can handle
so
that issue as i read the bill very very
quickly
does not appear to have been addressed
if somebody
disagrees with that
please jump in
um
but um
to me that was one of the main things
that gave me pause about a bill that in
a lot of ways i i think i agree with the
intent of it civil
civil asset forfeiture
is uh is not a happy thing
for a lot of people in this state um
and uh
and i do think that there are some
things that we need to do to to restrict
it but again
the devil is in the details and we have
11 pages more of details and i'm not
sure
to what extent they're solving the
i may be able to provide some insight
and representative burt you can thank me
thank you later
so
i do have a
what has been reported is this this
0874-h compared to the initial
non-germain amendment there are four
changes
one's on page two line thirty five
so there's only four
changes now i
compared to the non-initial non-german
amendment and what we have before the
because when i when i read this i didn't
find it to be
much of a difference but that's just
representative connolly
sort of echoing what representative muse
just articulated pretty well i i sort of
agree with those points but one of the
things that's standing out on this and
this came up during testimony for the
non-germain amendment
so we're essentially taking
a sort of swath of
property that could be subject to
forfeiture and saying it's off limits to
forfeiture regardless of whether or not
said property is subject or is is fruit
of a crime
so although it might seem like a small
amount currency totaling 200 or less a
vehicle
worth less than two thousand dollars
well
although
we like to think of forfeiture as
targeting kingpins
we know in new hampshire that the vast
majority and we heard this from
testimony the vast majority of
properties subject to forfeiture is
they you can have problems with
forfeiture and want to address them
but we also don't want to make it so bad
actors get to keep their ill-gotten
gains and i think that that's possible
representative true
thank you mr chair and i i i did try to
could you write down
run by those changes in the pages again
a little slower
and in page 4 line 32
charging instrument has been changed to
indictment or
information and that same
grammatical change was actually changed
again on page five line
eight and page five line fourteen
so that's the same
uh
wording change that was multiple
it and in respect to the non-germain
amendment the idea
at least the
goal was to have a situation where when
you have these asset forfeiture hearings
it's a several civil case
and there was some thought that it may
save the court time and save
a lot of the interested party's time if
you
at the end of a criminal
prosecution if
whether convict if they're convicted
perhaps just have that civil
instead of having a separate civil case
you can you have a lot of the court the
judge the fact the lawyers everyone's
familiar with with the facts of what
just happened it might have saved
all the interested parties time
legal expenses everything to just have
that
hearing done right then and there
so the the intent of this is actually i
believe in the right place whether this
accomplishes that's really what i'm
hoping we can
discuss amongst ourselves today and make
a decision on
but having to pay
a lawyer to represent you in a separate
civil case involving asset forfeiture
when you don't the
court
may not always you may have a different
judge who's not as familiar with the
facts of the case literally at the end
of the trial
i assume it's fresh in everyone's mind i
don't i don't see the the harm in having
that hearing
right then however
i just oversimplified the issue
so whether this accomplishes that
both procedurally and
fundamentally is what i would hope we
can decide on today
represent a board name
thank you mr chair
and i do not think that you miss a
representative of the facts
but where did you get the information on
is that relevant
uh yes because did you examine yourself
or did someone tell you well i already
told you that i don't have the actual
an initial original
non-germain amendment however
the sponsor the bill did for it
forwarded me that information
so to the extent that it is accurate or
inaccurate
i have no reason to not not believe that
that would be accurate
just trying to figure out whether we're
looking at something accurate or not i
will say if that email came from
representative board now i also would
take the email and
give it the same
same credibility one way or another so
if it turns out there's more
what any other members of the committee
if you are in support of adopting
amendment
2022-0874-h please say yay
if you're opposed
please say nay the clerk will not call
the roll
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
yes
representative burke yes representative
pearson yes
representative green yes
clerk votes yes representative berry yes
representative true
yay
representative pratt
yes representative marston
yes
representative sue newman yes
representative o'hearn
yes
representative bordenay
no
representative muse
representative ray newman
yes
representative heath no
representative conley
no
representable flam yes
representative hamlet
no
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
16 yays five nays
the amendments adopted
representative burt you wish to be
recognized to make a most of ought to
pass as amended
yes uh mr chairman i make a motion of
ought to pass as amended on house bill
12 96
is is there a second
it has been seconded by representative
wallace
representative bert do you wish to speak
to your motion
i think we spoke enough on this it just
you know bottom line this this bill
will put
the burden on to the state
to
say if
any money seized is for drug purposes
um
and i think it's a good amen uh good
question of the chair representative
calling thank you can you remind me and
the committee because we've heard
there's so many amendments and there's
an undermay amendment hearing is this
the bill that would flip it from you
know the burden of proof being
50.1
for the plaintiff versus the state to
now the state has that burden of proof
is that is that this bill or is that one
of the different asset forfeiture bills
i think representative
you can represent
gather you can address that question
and one uh one final reminder without
hearing again from the judicial system
um
to see whether this amendment actually
does anything to solve the problem that
they raised during the public hearing
pass
what looks to be a very complicated
procedure
that will require a fair amount of
training
throughout the court system um you know
in order to implement um
uh
regardless of the fact that the bill is
you know it's obviously well intended
and it does take care of an issue i
think
part of the challenge for us as
lawmakers is to try and solve one
problem without creating another
representative bourdain
thank you mr chairman um
considering
i think i do think that possibly this is
a
improvement in law
but you can't quote me on that because i
really don't know what's in it
and i'm still not going to support the
bill
because
an unknown
do any members wish to speak they have
i see no hands raised at this time when
i'll move the question
if you're in support of the motion about
to pass as amended
please say yay if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk will not call
the roll
vice chairman roy
yes representative welch
yes
representative burt
yes representative pearson yes
representative greene yes clark votes
yes representative berry yes
representative true yay representative
pratt yes
representative marston
yay
representative harriet gathright
representative sue newman
no
representative o'hearn
no representative bordenay
no
representative muse
representative ray newman
no
representative heath
representative connolly no
representative laflamme
no
representative hamlet no
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
mr chairman i'll have a uh
my majority
thank you representative burt
representative muse
at this time we will now close the
at this time we will now open the
executive session on house bill 1105
representative roy you wish to be
recognized
yes i like to make uh a motion
i did have my hand raised i didn't see
one from
uh yes thank you mr chairman i would
like to move
on to pass
represent boarding wish to second that
motion
is there a second
oh second
that's been seconded by representative
welch
any representative where you wish to
speak to your motion yes briefly
um this bill was brought to us
with the intention of fixing what um i
see as a grievous grievous um
situation where whereby
an inmate can take
and utilize
short video courses um taken on an ipad
to shave months and months and months
off their sentence
as kind of a catch-all versus um having
to take a legitimate and and vetted
course
that that invested more of their time
and energy um and this the way it was
set up and the way it's run right now
is
ripe for abuse i think that the
commissioner
we have currently is is
excellent but we have to look at this
from a perspective of of the future
and where by all the other
mechanisms
to get earn time credit they're only
allowed to use once
this specific
program allows them to use it multiple
times
so they can get time off their sentence
by simply laying in their bunk and
watching a video on an ipad i just don't
think that was the intent of this
program
representative bourdain
vic chairman
um
if i remember correctly from
the commissioner of corrections
um
she stated that she spends
at least eight hours
a week
on earned time off
and that includes evaluating the courses
and the materials that the person who
and she is very interested in
the improvement of
inmates
she does not want inmates to go out in
the world earlier than
necessary
unless there is some changes made
she
has also the power
to
say okay you you say you earned their
time off but we actually
are not going to give you credit for
that
what else oh and
the
ex-chair of the parole board
said
in her evaluation of the tablet program
that she did not think it was good
enough for earned time off but she had
never had access to the tablet program
so she doesn't know what she was
evaluating
so
based on the character of the
commissioner of corrections
and her
desire to have good results
and i have to trust that she is doing
her job adequately
and i put my trust in her
then i would not
in respect of the earned times credit
program
for there is
under existing law this
is sections a through e under rsa 651
a colon 22-a
the maximum amount of earned time
credits that anyone anyone can receive
and if you look at the rsa as a whole
not just the snapshot of what the what
hb 1105 is
you
this subsection f excludes sections a
through e
section a involves education programs
now it goes all the way from
a high school diploma all the way to a
doctorate degree
but each one of those degrees
is a one-time
benefit and you can get depending on
which degree you get 90 to 120 days or
180 days
section
b
is vocational programs that is also a
one-time
reduction
that's that's as it's written
section c's mental health program
says one-time reduction of 60 days each
program
says one-time reduction i keep going
down the list
the only one that doesn't have the
one-time
reduction here
is um
section f which is really more of a
catch-all
and
there's nothing suggesting that that
the discretion that is permitted under
section f is being misused or abused
but there isn't much of a criteria other
than simply whether it's approved by the
commissioner
or not
in the difference between this section
and the other sections is is that any
inmate can take
any of the programs from a through e
and it would apply equally where under
section f
one inmate can complete a program
and another inmate can do that same
program and not necessarily get the earn
time credit
now there may be a reason for that and
part has to do is would that
tablet program
actually
do anything or maybe assist that i mean
inmate in rehabilitation
i think that's something that the
commissioner would would need to
decide
i my concern is is that this seems to be
a catch-all but also
in theory someone could
complete this
ten and a half times and they would
reach the 21 month
threshold
i feel that if someone wanted to try to
reduce their time they have the other
sections this expressly excludes the
other sections as well so
an inmate would still be able to
work towards getting the 21 months
earned times credit it's just they
wouldn't be limited on the catch-all
provision
what i would be supportive of too is
expanding well a through e if there are
other sections even added to that one of
them potentially could be getting a
professional license
uh some sometimes with a criminal record
a person could be excluded
from being eligible for those licenses
but we could always exclude those
include
excuse me expand those those
sections
so that's also an option but having a
catch-all that can be basically used
exclusively to
maximize earn time credit i don't think
that that's the intent of the
program
in my opinion that can even take away
from some of the other
programs in the mental health
section the
educational section
if a person is simply able to just
do a
listen to a lecture that's an hour long
on a tablet
that i i just feel it's too open-ended
and i'm i
think we can do something to perhaps
solve this problem but i see as written
now it it is ripe to be taken advantage
of
that's just my my opinion and i'm not
saying that that's happening now
so
that's the point of this bill if anyone
has any suggestions i'm
representative boyd name
thank you chairman i don't have a
suggestion
but
i will note that each of these earned
time credit reductions
are
approved has to be approved by the
commissioner so
for you to get credit for your high
school diploma
that has to be approved by the
commissioner
so
if the commissioner is approving all
earned time credit
then
they she
the commissioner knows
what they are getting for their value
what value they're getting for
the program
so i will still have to say if the
commissioner thinks
that a repeated
r
use of f
other programs
is warranted then
let's go for it
representative uh representative ray
newman
i know in the testimony we heard
we constantly heard about the prisoners
lying on their beds getting an hour time
and knocking off and getting an
additional amount of credit
through the year in time credits
i also
as best my recollection
that
i don't know that we heard from the
commissioner that that
how that happened to where that where
that information comes from
and i know that she did testify that she
wanted to
improve the way that the these the
tablets that they now have
in the prison
could be
used and there
and she wanted to make sure that the
programs that she did that
that she approved were ones that would
be of value to the people who were
taking the programs
and i just think this is again something
where we hear an anecdotal one-time
thing happened and it was in the
pandemic and
that may have happened
but i think that this door might there
might be a really good reason why people
should get maybe maybe they could have
two of these courses and we have the
commissioner who who understands
the value of it and is trying to improve
it and i'm afraid that this will
close the door on multiple use of this
and multiple use of the tablets and
therefore i can't support this bill
if i may inquire with with a question
if i say the word amendment is i'm going
to say a point of order
are you asking me about it
if there was an amendment
per se
an improvement to the bill not
that allowed it to be taken
two times
under section
f
i would be supportive of a policy i
don't know that we know what the number
is that is the correct limitation that
the commissioner believes ought to be
allowed in order to
make accurate use of this program which
is on the tablet and the tablet's a new
thing to the prisons
right now the numbers that we're closing
the door what right now the number would
be 11 that's how you would get to 21
months
so
that might not be the right number
either i'm just saying i'm afraid that
this slams the door on the opportunity
that we have for prisoners to get
rehabilitation in an adequate way and
i'm concerned about that and therefore i
will not support this bill
representative harrygath right
one of the things that i remember from
that
that day is that the commissioner stated
because it was said that people were
finishing the course within 15 30
minutes and things of that nature and
what she said was that she was looking
into that because
that she felt there was an issue with
whatever gives that information so it
wasn't enough data or true data to
actually determine if in fact that was
happening
so again
i'm like the rest of the team pretty
much um
a lot of respect for the commissioner
she does a great job
i feel that this takes that away from
her from doing her job
and i feel as though that she should be
the one to make that decision she knows
the prisoners better than you me or
anybody else around this table
representative muse
i think one one of the positive uh
things about having this hearing and
this discussion is
that a lot of us know a lot more now
about earned time credits than maybe we
ever wanted to know or ever thought we
were going to need to know
but one of the things
i i think we we really do need to keep
in mind is
we put people like commissioner hanks in
a position of authority for a reason we
allow them
to
to shape
their programs in a particular way
because
frankly they have
people like commissioner hanks have
just domain knowledge that we do not
have
she's interacting with inmates
virtually every day she's interacting
with their own victim services people
every day
there's no one who's more on top of this
situation in my opinion
than than than she is and
i feel like
when we when we pass bills like this
as as well-intentioned as we may be
one of the things that we're doing is
we're
interjecting
the legislature
into yet another issue where
we
with all good intentions try to
micromanage an issue
that
maybe a few hours really trying to pick
my tendency here is
essentially is
without
without knowing uh you know more about
this system without knowing more about
these programs without knowing a lot
more about their impact on prisoners
this just strikes me as just a very
precise
technical way to just
put a handicap
in front of the ability of the
commissioner
to rehabilitate um the people under her
charge
and and i think it's something we really
all need to think twice about before we
do i mean one of the goals i know
that we're you know that
one of the things i think most of us
have been able to agree on
uh in this in this legislative session
is
having people in
in prison um you know with no hope of
getting out and with little hope of
rehabilitation is not a good thing for
them it's not a good thing it's not a
good thing for the state
so the idea is to get people out
you know who just don't agree that this
is the right way to come at the problem
so one
one one positive from all of our healthy
discussions here is
this is section f is a is a new
new policy and from what i understand
it was kind of put in as
part of an ominous bill and at least
before the house in this committee
the policy that is section f was not
something we discussed as a committee
last term
whether the ought to
pass passes or if it's
whatever happens thereafter
at the very least
this committee had had the discussion
we've had the hearings in this room
so if we don't pass this we at least did
our due diligence by
not compromising it on and voting one
way or another as part of an ominous
bill it's really it's now had its
hearing before this committee
and we'll see how it goes so i think we
at least did that and we earned a lot
about earntime credits and i will tell
you this representative muse if there is
a bill to
add a section about professional
licenses i hope you asked me to
representative true
thank you mr chair
i know uh when the commissioner was here
she
she told us she was not in favor of the
bill
and
i think some of the problems that some
people might be looking at
with the end time credit program is the
uh is the tablets that's that's a that's
a new program
uh but the commission did say that um
there are
classes that are set up
because
the a large
section of the prison population is
poorly educated
so they're probably not going to get a
master's degree
a business degree or even a high school
diploma
um
and and i think the uh the tablet was a
way to maybe reach out
to the uh
less educated to get them involved with
if if somebody is able to go on a tablet
program
and do
11 programs to
[Music]
theoretically earned 21 months off of
their sentence
i would say that's abuse
and i believe the commissioner said it's
up to the commissioner to monitor for
any abuse
so that somebody could do
11 tablet programs
that would have been worth 21 months and
the commissioner could rule that it's
worth
120 days
and that's all you're going to get for
it
knowing as little as i do about end time
credit
i would have to uh favor going along
with the recommendations of the
commissioner
and and not favor the bill
at this time we can now move the
question if you can support the motion
of ought to pass please say
yeah if you're opposed please say nay
the clerk will now call the roll
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
representative burt
yes
representative pearson yes
representative greene
yes
clark votes no
representative
pierce uh hang on a second i've got a
yes
yes thank you ross
representative barry
representative true
nay
representative pratt yes
no
representative sue newman no
representative o'hearn
no
representative bordenay no
representative muse
no
representative ray newman
representative heath no
representative conley
no
representative laflem no
representative hamlet no
and chairman abbas
i stand corrected eight years thirteen
days
representative welch do you wish to make
so i'll move
is is that seconded by representative
portney
uh mr chair i can't say
that's been the interim study motion's
been seconded by representative roy
i'm just trying to get a read on you
this time we can now move the question
if you're in support of the motion to
interim study
please say
hey if you're opposed
please say nay the clerk and i'll call
the roll vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
yes
representative burt yes representative
pearson
yes
representative greene yes clerk votes
okay
representative true
yay
representative pratt yes
representative marston
yes
representative sue newman
no
representative o'hearn
representative bordenay
yes
representative muse
no
representative ray newman
representative heath no
representative conley
yes
representable flam no
representative hamlet yes
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
uh there was a representative not in
their seat
whoever representative barry is
motion for interim study passes would
at this time we will now close the
representative true are you ready on
hb1246
we have we have other other bills we can
mr chair representative
fourth floor did say they'd call down
and let the office know
representative welch
there was some inquiry about h.b 11
excuse me 1335 that was relative to the
parole board and the procedure for
medical parole of prisoners
i know there was
two
word-for-word identical
amendments i did you speak with
yes uh the
the reason there's two amendments is
because the the folks
from the parole board had sent it out to
representative murphy and they also sent
it out to me and a couple of others
i put mine in first
and representative murphy put his in
second and i was inquired by uh by the
uh ols as to why had there two identical
bills i explained it to him and i says
put both names on one bill but they
chose to
come up with two separate amendments
they're both they're identical
what i'm inquiring about there is a
subcommittee scheduled on friday
i'm just wondering
is is this ready to be called today
it is it is ready
um does it i know representative muse
you're also on that that
i um
i am in agreement with representative
welch's amendment um but what i am
uh
not 100 sure of is whether it addresses
all of the issues that were raised at
the hearing but it does seem to address
i am okay
if uh representative welch chooses to
hear it today
it's up to him
we now open the executive session house
bill 13
relative to the parole board and the
representative welch we should be
recognized to make a motion
i make a motion that
house bill 1335 fn the ought to pass as
amended
and you wish to offer offer an amendment
representative bourdain wish to second
that yes i do second
and do all the members
do all members have a copy of amendment
and in representative green from i
understand the two amendments are
word-for-word identical
and i just thought of respect the fact
that one member was a member of the
committee i just
representative welch was to speak to the
amendment
the the amendment clarifies uh
language that was in the bill it only
amends section three of the original
bill
and what it does
it clarifies
the the
quantifies the practice that they're
the change
on the amendment on line 11.
it says the medical parole
request
shall
cite one of the following medical
categories and then the amendment that
was forwarded to me there was
it said should
shell is the operative word and that's
what we use
and they were okay with that i
showed the amendment down there to the
representative from the department of
from the parole board
and everything is
the way they wanted it
the one exception
is
in in the statutes they talk about
prisoners and in this
amendment we talk about residents
and i guess the appropriate modern term
is resident not prisoners
and
yeah i'm going to support this because
basically what it does is it does put
some good guardrails around this process
um and i think it really clarifies uh
and helps people better understand uh
when
uh residents are eligible for this and
and when they're not
i also think that
some of these criteria criteria also
reduce the risk of something i think
that some people were concerned about
during the hearing which is the
possibility of a person receiving
medical parole
who then just gets better and all of a
sudden you know there they are out of
prison with no supervision
so um it it tightens the criteria it
makes things more specific it puts
guardrails around the process
um
and uh and the language uh meets with
the uh approved the exacting
requirements of the department of
corrections
do any member representative true
thank you mr chairman it may be a
question of uh
of the chair and he can refer to whoever
you wish
uh department of corrections originally
was opposed
to the uh to the bill
uh but department of corrections now
says there they they agree with the bill
representative welch was to address that
i believe what had happened is that the
parole board and the commissioner of
corrections got together and they
produced this amendment
and uh it was emailed out to us
and has been copied into
the amendment you see before you and
i've shown
i took the amendment down and
we got the knot of approval from the
parole board
representative boarding
actually i
checked my notes the commissioner was in
favor of the bill but stated it needed
an amendment
so
is that your play way of encouraging the
chair to move the question
at this time when i moved the question
if you're in support of adopting
please say yay you're opposed please say
nay the clerk will not call the role
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch
yes representative burt yes
representative pearson
yes
representative greene yes
clark votes yes representative berry yes
representative true yay representative
pratt yes representative marston
yay
representative harriet gathright yes
representative sue newman yes
representative o'hearn yes
representative bordenay yes
representative muse
yes
representative ray newman
representative heath yes
representative conley
yes
representative flam yes
representative hamlet yes chairman abbas
the chair of ots
the amendment has been adopted
and represented welch you recognized to
i shall move
representative you should wish to second
that
second
motion was seconded by
representative muse
any members wish to speak to the
question
this time we'll now move the question if
you in support of the motion of ought to
pass as amended please say yay
if you are opposed please say nay the
clerk will now call the ruler
vice chairman roy yes representative
welch
yes representative burt yes
representative pearson yes
representative greene yes clerk votes
yes representative berry yes
representative true
yay
representative pratt yes
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright
representative sue newman yes
representative o'hearn yes
representative bourdain yes
representative muse yes representative
ray newman
yes representative heath yes
representative connolly
yes representative leflam yes
representative hamlet yes
chairman abbas the chair votes yes
21 years zero nays
and
representatives you wish to do the
sure
and this time
we will now close the executive session
this time with the committee's going to
be in recess
graduated
hello
this time we're going to open the
executive session on house bill
hp 1246 relative to interlock interlock
devices
representative welch should be
recognized to make a motion about to
pass
i move that we
pass house bill
no
representative welch wish to speak to
your motion
representative true you wish to speak to
you
uh yes i'd like to speak to the to the
motion of otpa i'd like to offer an
amendment to house bill 1246
i'd like to offer amendment
2022-0920
and i would like to speak to my
amendment
you recognize to speak to the amendment
on
line 10
11 and 12
is referring to the fact that
the the offender
must
have interlocked devices put in all
vehicles that are registered under his
name
given a scenario that uh
he has four cars
one for his son one for his daughter one
for his wife and they're all under his
name
it is my opinion that that is an
excessive penalty financially
to the family
an israelite device costing anywhere
between one and two thousand dollars per
vehicle
eight thousand dollars
to uh
to qualify
under the original bill
what my bill does it removes the
the stipulation that all vehicles
registered
under his name
must have the interlock device
and it changes that to
the vehicle being driven
by the offender must have an interlock
and i offer that amendment just because
i feel that the original bill
granted original law
already in law was too excessive
it was excessive to the family
that did nothing wrong
and the idea is to
to uh qualify the offender to drive only
a vehicle that has interlocked devices
and that's what i feel the amendment
does
thank you mr chair
i'm just going to this is gonna be very
straightforward we had a bill last that
hb
1085. and we discussed this exact issue
for a very long time i want to say about
45 minutes
give or take
on the issue of interlocking devices on
any vehicle that's registered to the
individual and we
so now we're hearing the same
it's now on a different bill
the
the amendment would basically say all
right it's registering your name but if
you don't drive the vehicle on a regular
basis you don't have to put the
interlocking device in the vehicle
the idea is
it doesn't say that no it does not say
what it says is
if you uh under this law
and you are required to have an
interlock device in the vehicle that you
that's the whole purpose of the law in
the first place
yes
not that you're driving occasionally or
anything like that
because the car you're driving if you
are stopped the car you are driving has
an interlock device in it
i understand and what the point that i'm
going to make is that if a person were
to violate said law
and therefore drive a vehicle that does
not have the interlock device in there
the system in and of itself has already
failed
the idea is that they don't drive any
vehicle period without this i understand
the way it's written but it is not an
unreasonable to presume that if a
vehicle is registered in someone's name
that they will operate that vehicle
and the easiest way to avoid having the
interlocking device in your vehicle
is to not commit an aggravated offense
where you either get in an accident
while impaired or
you're double the legal limit and then
also convicted of
or it's a subsequent offense so it's a
second third offense or higher
i think we create a relatively low
standard to avoid having this
interlocking device problem
come up
so
i'm not going to support the amendment
the what the underlying
but the amendment still does do and what
the bill would do is it has to do where
it takes the consideration
offenses and other jurisdictions
someone could move here
if they were to move here
well they would again be getting around
the requirement of the interlocking
device
the
this was supposed to prevent that from
happening where someone can just say oh
well yeah it's not working out for me
so
this is trying to avoid that now again
if you have all these vehicles register
your name
i think it's fair to say that you it's a
strong likelihood that you're going to
drive that vehicle
and
i'm not going to support this amendment
i think this this what this does is
defeats the purpose of the underlying
law and we rejected the same
suggested change in policy last week
representative roy you're recognized
thank you mr chairman
i'll start off by saying i agree with my
good friend representative true that
this is a
a costly uh burden on an operator in
this family
and i would pose the hypothetical
let's say we just did away with this
section of law entirely regarding
interlocked devices where would that
leave us that would leave us with these
people would not be able to drive at all
their licenses would be revoked and they
would not be able to drive at all
so in
consideration of them
and
their family allowing them an
opportunity one more time after they've
been convicted twice to be able to drive
and go out and earn a living
we are allowing them to have access to
vehicles with interlocking devices and
the reason is because what this is is
this is a physical or a mechanical
barrier
we've already tried the law they've
ignored that several times
well now we need a physical barrier to
stop them because they just can't seem
to understand that you should not drink
and drive
so while this is costly there is no
doubt um driving as i said previously on
the other bill is a privilege it is not
a right
and where we did just strike this entire
portion of laura they would be left with
a suspended license and have no
opportunity to drive and provide for
their family so i i feel that
by
requiring them to have an interlock
device in all of their vehicles
the point is is it provides a physical
barrier because they obviously cannot
understand the law that says you can't
drink and drive so now we're going to
say okay we'll give you one more try but
now we're going to make it really
difficult
for you to drink and drive you're going
to have to take a breathalyzer every
time behind you get behind the wheel
no one's forced them to do that they
could turn that down they could say you
know what i don't want that i don't want
these interlock devices i don't want
them at all well
that's your right too you don't drive
so i feel like again
while i understand this is a costly
burden but it's not one that's forced on
anyone it's one they choose to accept
they can say i don't want to drive
anymore and i want to pay that
that's fine
but in order to earn that privilege
after having been convicted multiple
times for drinking and driving
um i feel like this is
i think the the state bending over
backwards to let them have a chance to
representative wallace
thank you mr chair and thanks for taking
my question representative um in your
situation or if this would have become
law
what is going to stop that individual
who's been
convicted of aggravated oui or
subsequent offenses who has this
interlock device in their motor vehicle
but only in
the father's motor vehicle in your
hypothetical what is to prevent him from
using his son's car
while the son is at school uh because
he's going to run down to the store to
get something after he's been working in
the yard drinking beer mowing his lawn
what's going to prevent him from
the only thing that would prevent him
from operating that vehicle is if he was
stopped while driving
then this law would
take full force against him via not
being in compliance
if he had all four of his cars
registered in his name with the
interlock device what's going to stop
him from borrowing his neighbor's car
should we have the neighbors should he
pay for his neighbor to have interlock
you can't if a guy is going to break a
law he's going to break a law
the law says
in with the amendment or even without
the amendment um
here's your chance the car you're
driving must have an interlock device in
it
do you know if you drive without an
interlock device then you're in
violation
so what would stop him from borrowing
his friend's car
would be the police stop
that's what would stop him from
borrowing the friend's car because then
he has to answer to the court for that
well
just to understand the neighbor the
friend
they're not you can't the court can't
order an interlock device to go in the
neighbor's vehicle
they have nothing to do with the
underlying realize that there's nothing
to stop him from borrowing somebody's
car
exactly but the idea of this this entire
policy is to try to prevent the person
from operating a motor vehicle as much
as we can
by requiring them to to have an
interlocking device any vehicles that
they either are driving or there's a
strong likelihood that they will operate
which again a car registered in their
name that is a fair presumption to make
there's no reason to think that that
would not happen
so
again i'm just going to remind you when
we completely rejected this policy last
week
if someone's
was discussed for about 45 minutes i
the committee
collectively did
the majority of the committee thank you
representative
thank you mr chair
um
i'm not going to
oppose this bill
in fact i'm going to
ask the question you know
part of
part of the issue and probably the
biggest part of the issue is
that
this country as well as the
state has a real difficulty with alcohol
and alcoholism
and
while the interlock devices
can
do work some of the of the issue
we actually need to
figure out
some way
to address the alcohol issue
and
these workarounds
they don't really address the real cause
representative
thank you mr chairman
um
is there anything that would prevent
someone who owned for who had four
registered cars from transferring three
of those registrations to somebody else
and thereby avoiding having to have
interlocked devices in every car that he
it's america people are generally free
to transfer their property
freely and willingly
and as they see fit so no i'm not aware
of any law that would restrict that
person from
transferring the vehicles
or taking their name off the
registration
any members wish to speak that have not
spoke already
the question is to adopt the amendment
and i'll just repeat i would support not
to pass but i'm not i would not support
this amendment
this is
where i stand representative ray newman
you wish to speak
yeah i
having had experience with some
relatives that had to use interlock
devices and understanding the the
problem with having the other members of
the family might be using the the all
the vehicles that are registered to the
person
and we all talked and we had testimony
that was about
how difficult it is for another person
to be able to drive a car like that and
go through the thing with the flashing
lights and having to pull over and do
all that kind of stuff
so i'm just thinking that this license
and requirement is just an
initial
just an initial expense to those
families some families that would have
the benefit of maybe a
wage earner
not having to drive a car
with an interlock device on it because
someone in the family is required to
have one and why you have to
if you i don't think you solved your
problem that you're apparently
attempting to do
by having them having to register all
their vehicles no matter how many there
are
i mean we should have if somebody has a
court order to to not drive a car
without an interlock device
then they should be held fully
accountable when they drive a car
without an interlock device
and but putting that extra burden on
families again we're kind of doing
around the corner
try to fix it and and i don't think that
it reaches whatever we're trying to get
here thank you
if if i may respond to what is there any
concern about the burden
towards other families when this is an
aggravated situation where someone is
involved in an accident because they're
impaired
or we're now dealing with someone who's
been convicted for the second or third
or fourth time
so we're dealing with a repeat offender
and we're trying to prevent that conduct
from continuing to happen that every
time it happens puts it poses a threat
to public safety we're trying to
mitigate it as much as we can i mean
we're not going to stop at 100 percent
we can't do that
may i respond so all i'm suggesting is
by
we're worried about the financial burden
on the person who continues to violate
the law repeatedly and endanger public
safety
and i can certainly appreciate it
because it can
it still can become exciting it can
become excessive i agree but in this
circumstance
we're talking about aggravated offenses
and repeat offenses that put everyone
and every member of the public at risk
without exception so
it's just a matter of being fortunate
that no one's harmed and that's that's a
best case scenario that no one got
injured so i i'm concerned why
uh everyone's sympathizing for the
person who has to use the interlocking
device but we're forgetting how that
what that person did in order to be at
the point where they are now required to
have an interlocking device in their
vehicle in the first place
may i respond you may respond
representative thank you
unfortunately my computer is i don't
have my recharging card with me and i
haven't read each one of these rsas i've
read them before but don't remember now
does this only applies to aggravated
offense situations
in what second or third i couldn't find
second or third searching the bill so
and
don't have my book my book is
missing
is that is it a question
i guess my question would be does does
would this apply to an individual on a
first offense
it would not okay thank you it would if
it was an aggravated offense meaning you
were
double the legal limit which is .16
or you're involved in an accident well
impaired
thank you represent or you are impaired
and when a police officer attempts to
stop your vehicle you would tend to
well not not run on foot
flee
flee by vehicle
engage in a high speed chase and not
pull over
already operating the motor vehicle
thank you
and just so you know um
rsa
i believe that's that's referring to so
you know to manslaughter
so i mean we're not talking about
egregious situations here
financial burden aside
but at this time when i'll move the
question support of adopting the
amendment
please say yay
if you are
opposed to adopting the amendment
please say nay the clerk will not call
the roll vice chairman roy no
representative welch
no
representative burt
representative pearson no
no
clerk votes no representative barry
yay
representative pratt
no
representative marston
representative sue newman
no
representative o'hearn
representative boardney no
representative muse
no
representative ray newman
representative heath no
representative conley
no
representative laflem
yes
representative hamlet
no
chairman abbas
the chair votes no
three years 17 nays one not voting the
back to the original motion of ought to
pass
representative well she wished to
discuss the
i don't have the bill in front of me
and i got
and just correct correct me if i'm wrong
what this really would do is it really
just allows you to take into
consideration out of state conviction so
if someone were to move here or i
suppose if you live here and we're
driving another state
it would be able to take that in
consideration when it comes to
the interlocking device so if you were
to commit uh
vehicular manslaughter in another
jurisdiction well the state of new
hampshire could require an interlocking
device in your vehicle
that's what the underlying
do any members wish to speak on the
seeing no hands
i'm
so we take into consideration an
out-of-state
problem
and that would then
this time
when i move the question if you in
support of the motive ought to pass
please say yay if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk will not call
the roll
vice chairman roy yes representative
welch yes
representative burt
representative pearson yes
representative greene yes
clark votes yes representative berry yes
representative true
nay
representative pratt
yes
representative harriet garth wright
no
representative sue newman yes
representative o'hearn
yes
representative bordenay yes
representative muse
yes
representative ray newman
yes representative heath yes
representative conley yes
representable flam yes representative
hamlet yes chairman abbas
chair votes yes
anyone any member wish to move for
consent
at this time we will now close the
executive session on house bill
would there be
it can be removed from the consent at
at this time
we will now open the executive
session on house bill
1476 relative to persons arrested while
representative connolly you wish to be
recognized to make a motion
mr chairman i'd move out to pass on hp
1476 with amendment
2022-0895-h
does a member wish to second that motion
it has been seconded by representative
roy
the representative callie we should
speak to the motion
i will mr chairman what we have before
us with this amendment represents a real
compromise
uh from the original bill that takes
into account concerns raised by this
committee
around the initial proposal so
uh
what this bill would or what the
amendment would do
is reduce the amount of time somebody
could be held
uh pending coming before a judge
and it would create it would change the
standard
by which somebody would need to come
under the current so essentially it
retains the intent and tenants of the
bail reform proposal that passed uh
three or four years ago for all first uh
for all first arrests
for somebody arrested a second time
for a charge that exceeds a class b
misdemeanor that person would be subject
to seeing a judge before their bail
could be determined and the judge would
make that decision
for somebody who is charged with only
class b misdemeanor something that does
not
require jail time
it would require a third arrest so an
initial arrest and two more arrests
before that person would be held for no
more than 36 hours before coming before
a judge
and again this is a compromise
this is not sb 92 that this committee
saw last year and this is not
sb 294 which we will see later this year
both of those far exceeded the
provisions in this
and i won't say any more because the the
person who drafted this happens to be in
the room but i support this and and will
representative
barry you're recognized thank you mr
chairman and thank you for the committee
for having me in today i've no
substitutes speaking is not always
seen with uh
it's not it's always smiled upon but um
you know i've been here all day i
haven't opined on anything else you guys
know
what
bail reform means to
the communities that i represent um
there are this is a bipartisan bill
um
if there are for those who do not know
the history i am not um the largest fan
of manchester's mayor
but she agrees with this bill and her
and i don't often agree
so uh if that alone should give you an
idea that there's um
there's
near universal appeal for this we're not
talking about
we're not talking about changing
the original
pr bail statute when you're arrested the
first time this bill doesn't touch you
we are talking about people who are
already out on bail and are arrested
again for serious crimes with this
amendment
we're now we're now dealing with serious
crimes the
class b misdemeanors was brought in to
address concerns because we have been
working with all parties in this from
the beginning the concern was raised hey
are you going to hold somebody over the
weekend for a j for a crime that doesn't
hold jail time we said well let's fix
that so that's what this amendment does
it also addresses another concern of a
72-hour hold so we are cutting it in
half to 36 hours
we have compromised again and again and
again
and i'm asking you to put your
preconceived notions about this behind
behind you
and look at what we are talking about on
the underlying bill we're talking about
people who are already out on bail they
have already been arrested once and now
they've been arrested for a class a
misdemeanor or hire while out on bail
and all we're saying
is this person should go before a judge
don't put them in front of a bail
commissioner they need to go in front of
a judge if you've been arrested to or in
this case now three times
something is going on in your life
that requires someone other than a bail
commissioner to adjudicate you
maybe you are mentally ill
maybe you are experiencing homelessness
maybe there is something else going on
in your world that has caused you
to be arrested repeatedly these are the
people we are talking about they need
help
not all of them are bad people
they need help i view this as a bill
that helps them
get them in front of someone then that
can that can help them a bail
commissioner cannot help them a judge
can help them so i urge this committee
ought to pass submitted we have
compromised again and again and in fact
when this amendment was brought forward
one of the complaints was are you
watering it down too much and i said we
need to pass something we need to
address it so i urge the committee
any
silence
representative sue newman yes
may i ask that representative a question
yes and representative you may respond
to the question if you are able to
answer it thank you
for for my benefit could you please
explain
your opinion on the difference between a
person seeing a judge
versus a bail commissioner
so so yes um the the issue
the issue of a bail
and i spoke this in my in my testimony
when i when i introduced the bill
there the entire issue
of pr bail and how we're handling repeat
offenders is not being managed well in
my opinion
people who are arrested again and again
and again there's something going on
with them
and i
in the very first year i introduced a
bill to try to address the bail
commissioners because when i spoke with
stakeholders including members of law
enforcement virtually everyone pointed
to the bail commissioners
that that happened
so i introduced a bill to adjust
excuse me how the bail commissioners
were basically who they reported to how
often they would be
renewed and those sort of things
and the legislator had zero interest in
it and they basically the bail
commissioners blame the judges
when something in bail doesn't go right
because they say well we report to the
judges we're following the judge's
orders
so by putting these people in front of
the judge we're putting them in front of
the person that is supposed to be
overseeing the bail commissioner and my
hope is that the judges will
do a better job which i believe they
will i i'm not trying to say bail
commissioners aren't good people they're
not smart but i think a judge will do a
better job
um in getting them the appropriate bail
or help or you know preliminary you know
adjudication that they need because
clearly the system is failing them and
that doesn't necessarily mean that the
bail commissioner in that in exact
instance failed him but we need to kind
of kick that person up the chain a
little bit
because clearly the system is failing
them if you've been arrested three times
while you're already out on bail the
representative marston
thank you mr chairman
as i understand it
just simply stated a bail commissioner
cannot ask or put somebody
into a situation where they would have
to be evaluated
where a judge can
and that's the difference
that's why we want
the judge to get involved maybe
that second or third time depending on
the violation
because a judge has a lot more latitude
he can inquire as to what the background
of this person is and so on
and he can maybe put this person in a
mental institution and that was a
problem in manchester a while back where
somebody should have been in that
category and didn't and really hurt a
young lady so the judges have more
leniency more
more way with all
while i'm extremely sympathetic with
what manchester and some of the other
larger cities in the state are are going
through
one of the things that we need to keep
in mind is that the additional hearings
will have a very real impact
again
on a circuit court that's already
overburdened
there is no fiscal note it's an
indeterminate fiscal note with this bill
no one during testimony was actually
able to quantify
how many cases we're talking about we
did hear
a lot of troubling anecdotes but we
didn't hear
much in the way of quantification of
these cases
which
basically sort of puts us in a position
if we pass this of kind of passing a
wild card
we really have
no idea how much this is going to cost
we have no idea what the impact is going
to be
again on a judicial system that's
already overburdened and
i i know we've heard and seen
lots of stories in the news about where
this particular
you know where there are our breakdowns
in the system
one of the things that we haven't heard
a ton about yet are breakdowns in our
judicial system but if if we keep
passing things like this without funding
them
and without even thinking about things
things like that
you know we're putting enormous pressure
on a system that's already extremely
overburdened
and when it comes to the existing bill
reform law
one of the things that the existing law
does is it does give it does provide a
mechanism
to keep dangerous people off the street
so i so again i i think it's one of
these things where all of us sort of
need to
kind of weigh and balance the
the pluses and the minuses but this is
definitely
not
all sunshine and roses um
there are some very real considerations
that come along with this bill that we
should be keeping in mind as we vote for
it
thank you
i just want to
clarify that this is the existing law
so any person charged with an offense
who is
or was at the time of the offense was
committed on released
pending trial
for a felony or misdemeanor all right so
it can even be a class b misdemeanor if
they get arrested for any offense
including a class b misdemeanor which is
an offense you can't go to you
the penalty is not to be incarcerated
under the existing law
that person
according to
the existing law can be held for up to
72 hours excluding the weekends and
holidays
what this does is it actually reduces it
to 36 hours
it
it's excluding the weekends and holidays
but there's not much we can do to
it's also excluding class b
misdemeanors which again is an offense
you can't be
can't go to jail for so the idea is why
would a person
now be held or have their bill
you know be be held for an extended
period of time for an offense they can't
serve jail time for in exchange for that
what this is doing is rather than just
go in front of a bail commissioner that
person will be held
and brought before a judge
so
this is
there are some provisions of this that
are
i think are
i would say much more favorable to
someone who's going through the criminal
justice system
it's it's not necessarily a rollback
or repeal of the bail reform that was
passed a few years ago but if someone's
being arrested several times on bail
it's trying to bring going before a bail
commissioner
it doesn't now they're going to be
brought in front of a judge
that's what this would do
so i believe it's a fair compromise
i don't this isn't i don't believe this
is an egregious
uh change in the law
and it is the hope is to avoid some of
the more egregious situations that have
happened
okay and of the chair just to clarify
what you just read
does it say shall or may in the current
law
it's uh the current law is is may and
the reason why is that if the court that
makes the determination they don't want
to have
the person brought before the court then
they would still be able to go to a bail
committee then they would be brought
before a bail commissioner this is
making the requirement that they're
brought before the bill commissioner so
it's necessary to change the word from
may to shell
but it by making that requirement more
strict there are some
uh other parts of this amendment that is
actually much i would say more lenient
to someone and particularly the 72-hour
provision you in theory you can be a
person be arrested friday night
and held to the to thursday if if monday
was a holiday
i resp ask another question
but this eliminates bail commissioners
that's
no it does not eliminate bail
commissioners altogether
in this particular situation where the
person has been arrested now multiple
times while already out on bill
in that scenario and is it the third
time
it's now it's it's now like the third
they've been
arrested at that point they wouldn't
they would go in front of a judge not a
bill commissioner the right to go in
front of the bail commission that that
procedure is not going to be afforded to
that individual can i ask another
another question just to clarify what
was said about what this actually says
in the law
and
i mean i i i just from what i see that's
been changed i don't see that
i mean it says um
or a person charged with a class b
misdemeanor
so uh but so to me it would mean that or
a person charged with a class b minor
can then shall be determined am i am i
no it says that they they shall they
it basically says
um that they that they shall go and they
shall be put in front of a judge so
they'll be detained until they see a
judge
um
because that's that's been raised before
about is this creating mandatory minimum
holds
um and the reality is is
if the judge is available right then and
there
there's
they may not even go inside of a cell
it's literally how quickly can you get
him in front of a judge
it's just about getting them in front of
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
letting me speak i know i'm just a sub
but i just want to i'm from manchester
um and aldermen as well as the state
representative
and i completely support this bill
i support it because in manchester we
week after week i i see and i hear
about the repeat offenders i see them
in our parks
we have an issue we have a serious
problem
and do i think this is the panacea no
but you know what it's a beginning going
in front of a judge begins to spark the
fact that what we need is a series of
services for these folks because they
probably need mental health they need
they need work
they need different services
but we don't have those in place right
now so in light of that
i plan to vote yes on this bill today
because my city needs this bill thank
you very much
representative rory
thank you mr chairman i just want to um
briefly address the concerns regarding
the the fiscal notes and the
and and while i'm very pleased to hear
my friend from portsmouth's concern over
this is solely within the the ability of
the court to manage the cost of this
the court
as we've heard controls the bail
commissioners
the court instructs the bill
commissioners and how they should be
issuing bail and not
so
with regard to whether or not someone's
released or not that's up to the courts
to instruct the bail commissioners
the courts are free to um conduct phone
bail hearings um they we already know
that we have judges on call 24 hours a
day for domestic violence issues over
the weekend the same judge could also
hear uh bail issues
um there's a there's a lot of room in
there for them to to um to move do they
need more judges perhaps and and we can
hear that in the next
next time it's time for a budget but but
currently we as the good representative
just said we have a serious public
safety issue that has to be dealt with
and i do not see
a bail hearing for someone who's been
out on their second or third bail
being a lengthy hearing that's going to
tie up the court perhaps 10 minutes at
most
and as i said it can be done over the
phone if they allocate the resources
that they already are using um over the
weekends and holidays so it's potential
if they so said it all we're asking is
that they
they handle it
um where it already is so i don't see
the additional expense
regardless of
what we've
heard could possibly be or might
possibly be we know that there's judges
representative conley thank you
one of the things we hear with this bill
is that this is a manchester bill
solving a manchester problem and
it's not a manchester only problem my
city of dover is a small city in a small
state and this problem is affecting us
it's affecting our neighbors in summer's
worth it's affecting our neighbors to
the north in rochester every city in
this state and every town of any size is
dealing with uh situations that would be
addressed by this bill
so
it's a statewide issue and this fix is
needed
representative harry catherine
well i um i sympathize with manchester
as well and all the other towns that
we're mentioning
um
i like to say that
we receive data
that talks about the crime rate
in all the different cities particularly
the largest cities and manchester is one
of them
and what i have
is that the crime rate is down
for three years
each year
down
you can't hear me
sorry
what i'm saying is that the total crime
rate is down 2018 2019-2020 i'm assuming
that you guys are referring to 2021
which i don't have the data on
also i see that the arrest rate is down
continuously going down in that city
manchester by itself
so what i'm saying is that we we have a
social issue and i don't think that it's
right to address a social issue by
locking people up
you don't know what that situation is
and no you don't have to necessarily i
know that we for example in nashua a
police officer can call one of the
social agencies to get
a person
you know
that person doesn't have to wait to go
to a court for a judge to say you need
help
they can automatically take a person to
saint joe's or one of the other
facilities so i'm not sure what
manchester's doing with the social
issues but i don't know maybe it's
something a conversation between mayors
that could help with that type of
situation but to say lock them up
i have a problem with that
and most of the people that are that are
doing or recommitting those crimes are
people that are homeless
so if you're homeless let me put you in
jail and
give you a home in jail
i have a problem with that
and this isn't new
and manchester's known they've had a
problem for a serious time like all the
other titles that have problems and
that's the way they're addressing it as
social issues not as a means to lock
representative pearson thank you uh
i can i'll give a little insight here
i've been a
firefighter in the city of manchester
for 18 years and i assure you that the
social aspect of what has occurred that
is going on and that you reference is in
fact being addressed
in manchester
but that only works to a point and it
only goes so far
and i think that we've the fire
department especially in in conjunction
with the manchester mental health has
made substantial
substantial efforts in this avenue
but again that only goes so far
and we have a clear problem
that needs to be addressed it is not
unique to manchester my constituents and
dairy deal with it in a little bit of a
different way
but
i i don't i don't want to see this
turned into
um you know us throwing darts at a map
here into who's got problems where and
this isn't this is an overreach this is
a much wider issue than just what the
queen city is dealing with so
i i know we can get on a tangent here
about specifics because manchester gets
a lot of tv cameras and a lot of press
and a lot of highlights but let's not
forget that the rest of the communities
that have to deal with this don't
necessarily just get the press but it
doesn't mean it's not they're not
have any members
wish to speak they have not spoke
already
representative board name
i'm really hesitant to talk about this
but i i will
speak one i can
uh interesting enough
in new york state
they passed
bell reform as well and now they're
looking at repealing
parts of bail reform
but one thing about
new york state is
they actually have data
and the data says
that they have
uh a two percent
uh
offense rate so if
someone's released on bell
two percent come back
now i can assume that this is really
basically the same statistics that we're
going to be looking at in the state
so that seems to be a minor problem
however we do know
that there are
issues in our cities
about
people that have mental illnesses
and people that are homeless
and
it seems to me
that and we have on a talk to the chief
ellenberg from manchester he says he
does prefer people to the
closed door
or open door or whatever whatever it is
open doors
project
which
helps some but it doesn't take care of
all the problems
and he identifies that some of the
issues our people
and
make it unpleasant enough that the
manager askes and asks them to leave
they don't leave the police come take
them away arrest them and take them away
and um
because he's not really
committed a a serious offense
they were are released again
and before you know it
he's back in that same business doing
the same kind of thing maybe
more aggravated
and
he has to the call call the police again
except
maybe
uh the second time hit the he is more
offensive towards the manager when he
asks he's asked to leave so
this is a problem that's not going to be
solved by putting people in prison
because prison is not going to resolve
the problem it probably is going to make
the problem worse because
this person
may be uh have mental illness and being
in jail is not going to be
a good experience for them
so
i don't know the answer
but we need to address this problem on a
wider scale than putting them in jail
representative roy
thank you mr chairman
um
one thing that we're you know i i heard
the representative talk about how
arrests are down
one thing you have to think about also
from a perspective of a police officer
this is a very tiring job and it's a
very hard job and it's a very dangerous
job and when you
arrest somebody and you end up getting
into a scruffa with them and you gotta
cuff them and wrestle with them and get
them in the
to see them walk out the door five
minutes later while you're still typing
your report um it's disheartening and
and then
to see them on the street again later
doing the same things
and you're not your arrest will go down
because the police just get tired of
arresting the same people for the same
thing over and over to see the courts or
or the bail commissioners just let them
walk out the door
at least if they have to go to the judge
the judge can look at and we're not
putting people in prison um this that's
not what this bill does this bill just
says that they have to go see a judge
before they can get back out instead of
just another revolving door through the
through the police station for a
personal requirements bill
so um
i think that there's a lot of aspects
and and we should also look at the the
burden this puts on our law enforcement
community to continually see the same
people walking in and out the door
before they can even finish the report
from the first arrest
thank you
and just to expand on that
when a person is brought in front of the
judge
there's nothing in this requiring the
prosecutor to request that that person
not be
given bail
it's not a it's not
making a suggestion one way or another
so
that's the prosecutor may make the
decision to not ask for bill it can it
certainly happen
that's not
an impossibility so just
keep that in mind
representative
coordinate
thank you
well
after the person's before the person has
been brought for the judge
the likelihood is that
that person's already been
in jail before he uh gets to the
courtroom so
well he's not been put to prison but he
has probably suffered some time in jail
at this
time is there any members of the
committee who wish to speak that have
this time we'll now move the question
the question
if you're in support of adopting the
amendment please say yay if you were
opposed
please say
nay the clerk will now call the rule
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
representative burt
representative pearson yes
representative green yes
clerk votes yes representative berry yes
representative true
yay
representative pratt yes representative
marston
yes representative harriet gathright
yes
representative sue newman
representative o'hearn
yes representative bourdain
no
representative muse
yes
representative ray newman yes
representative heath yes
representative conley yes
representative laflem yes
representative hamblet yes chairman
abbas
the chair votes yes
eighteen yays one nay
i'm i'm sorry nineteen
by a
nineteen years and one name the motion
remember i'm calling we should make a
motion of ought to pass as amended i'll
make that motion mr chairman second
that has been seconded by representative
wallace
nope
representative true you're recognized
i keep hearing that
it's implied anyway that it's it's these
don uh bail commissioners that uh
that are causing all these problems
the bail commissioner answers to the
judge
the judge can say
you are no longer a bail commissioner
because of this this and this
so i don't see
why people feel that the judge who is
allowing
the bail commissioners to let people out
is now going to be the one who can cure
the problem
we are talking about taking away the
personal freedom
of people
who have not only not been found guilty
of a crime
they haven't even been charged with a
crime
i can't support the state saying
we think you're so bad you should lose
for 36 hours
well let's not forget saturday and
sunday
and don't forget uh the the holiday on
monday
36 hours becomes
72 hours real quick
so
on paper the 36 hours looks like it's a
reduction
but it's a reduction but don't count
saturdays sundays and holidays saturdays
sundays and holidays that makes 72 hours
right there
my main objection is
take away
somebody's freedom
when they have not even been charged
with a violation
that's not going to require any jail
time even if they are found guilty
and that's why i can't support the otpa
representative true the existing law as
written for any offense a person can be
held for 72 hours excluding weekends and
holidays so that can really be almost
double
72 hours
rolling some of that part reducing that
time period
in the
other side of that is that being going
to be brought in from
a judge not a bail commissioner so
the issue of 72 hours
in the weekends that the existing law
that is a problem under current law that
is whether this bill passes or not
that the weekend that's an issue we have
in our system right now
this this is going to reduce the time
when the courts are open that a person
can be held
and right now it says any offense
so right now it can be a class b
misdemeanor as well an offense you
cannot serve time for a person could
be held for 72 hours then
if it's a long weekend because of a
holiday on top of that so
the concerns you raised this this bill
would improve
at least that issue
it would mitigate that
so just something that i would point out
now we're not saying that the bail
commissioners we're not pointing the
finger here we're just explaining that
when a person's arrested and they're
brought in front of a bail commissioner
they're held for a very short period of
time
and i think what we're trying to do here
the goal is that if a person's a repeat
offender they're brought before a judge
as opposed to a bail commission that
that is what we're trying to do the
person will be held for a longer period
of time
if they're arrested and you know seven
o'clock at night eight o'clock at night
they can be held in the morning so
that's that's what we're dealing that's
what this is doing is to not let that
person be released that night
then waive their arraignment and they
often don't even only show up at the
next hearing things like that can happen
so by putting the person in front of a
judge they're you know in a courtroom
and that's where the bail hearing would
uh
so the difference real one of the
differences between the existing law and
the proposed law
is
one
verb
ones that present law says
may be detained
while
the proposed bill says shall be detained
in in order to require the person to be
brought before a judge as opposed to a
bail commissioner you must change the
word made to shall there's no
that that's the reason for that
change in the language
if you leave it as may
i'm not sure that the bill has written
would actually
representative ray newman
thank you
i agree with both the representative
board here and representative true in
may shall mean shall and may means may
so it does change it it
it
shall is a requirement you shall do
something in may says you may do
something
so what what that is what the reason
that shell has to be there is so that
the person can't go before a bail
commissioner
so therefore we're saying here again
the bail commissioners are not doing
what they're supposed to do well let's
fix that
and and we've also i think i've also
heard testimony and i may have been
incorrect in the way i interpret it
is that
there's a judge around
24 hours on call but i i think i also
heard that that was for domestic
violence
and i think we had some testimony from a
police chief
and i asked him well why don't we just
have a judge on call 24 hours and my
understanding from him was we don't have
that for these kind of offend
things so i i think that if you have
equal justice under the law
monday through friday you should have it
on the weekends and that's why this bit
so
if you look at lines this is the
amendment this is lines 12
through 19 where
this language struck out
when it's a may
what is what happens is the court is
contacted now the court does not have to
have the person appear before the court
they can then and if that's the case and
the court does not want to do a bail
hearing in the court
then it would was uh revert back to the
bail commissioner system so the may to
shall again is making it so it does not
go to the bail commissioner and i don't
think it's unreasonable that someone
who's a repeat offender is held for
a short period of time
overnight to being brought into a court
especially when it's dealing with third
fourth offenses here
but that's
the reason why you change that word is
if if you don't change that word the
rest of the paragraph's not going to
make any sense because
there is no this is making it so there
is no alternative so it has to be
shallow
may i respond
representing you may respond you have to
respond
it is a shall so that you have to have
them go to a court and not see a bail
commissioner yes
may would let them still have a bail
commissioner on on afternoons and
weekends that's all i'm saying
and i think if you're going to have due
process in the middle of the week you
ought to have due process on the
weekends and we have that now
in what we have because we have a
judicial officer who is overseen by a
judge
and who
can correct the if one is is letting
people out when they shouldn't be
that person should not be a bail
commissioner before or should have
um
remedial training that's what we had in
the faa when somebody didn't do their
job right so i think in in in order to
have equal protection i believe that
shall should not be changed to me thank
you
representative rory
thank you
um
i'm concerned that we're we're really
focused on inconveniencing criminals um
could we could we realize several things
here first you have to be arrested
while on bail
okay that means you were once charged
with a crime there was probable cause to
think you committed a crime you were
arrested you were released on your own
personal recognizance and told do not
commit any more crimes you committed
another crime and you get arrested now
we fixed it so it's only class b
misdemeanors i mean excuse me class a
misdemeanors and above there's these now
we're getting serious crimes that you've
committed the second time while you're
on bail if you committed a
non-arrestable offense you had to be the
third time before you would be for a
judge so i'd like to hear some some some
of this similar sympathy about the
inconvenience of victims
who who we have already heard about of
people who have been hurt or injured by
people who have been repeatedly let out
on bail
all we're asking is in
due process what more do prosecution you
get than going to see a judge
that's what they're there for
that is the definition of due to process
that is the definition to be brought
before the court
and that is all we're asking is that
they be brought before the court with
regard to the 24 hour on call the
judicial system itself the judges could
say
judge you're on call for
domestic violence calls and you're also
going to handle bail calls we're not
going to micromanage the court to the
level to tell them how to assign their
personnel all we're doing is saying that
we are going to require that an actual
judge who's gone to law school who
understands the law who has seen these
cases
is going to hear you your case after
you've been released on the second time
that's all that we're saying
it baffles me it really does that we're
representative news i know you had your
hand up i
just
before
generally is if a member has not spoken
already wishes to speak i would
recognize them before that's why
if you wish to
i do i i do
one of the things that we is pretty
common in this committee mr chair is for
when during an executive session
when one of us has something to say you
rebut
another
uh representative has something to say
you rebut again
um i think representative newman
deserves a chance to respond in and he
will have that i just was giving you the
courtesy of allowing you to speak before
representing just because you haven't
spoke already well thank you for the
courtesy i can wait
representative newman raynerman you were
recognized
first of all i'm not
saying this out of the
of my sympathy for multiple time
offenders
because these people may or may not be
multiple time offenders
both times that they are there they're
charged they are innocent they haven't
been adjudicated
so all i'm looking for is having
equal justice for people on weekends and
and that change of that one word changes
it to where it takes away due process
something that we hear a lot about here
representative
representative muse you were recognized
one of something i'd also like to say is
that the issue of lack of quantification
is not just
a fiscal note problem um
a bill like this would be much better if
it came in a budget year because then we
could put a price tag on it and we'd
pass it and all the costs would be
accounted for
um the quantify the quantification issue
um
also relates to who these people are so
so i think one of the things that we get
the impression of when we read the
newspaper and we hear the stories
is that
virtually all of the people
who fall into this situation are are
violent offenders
um they're they're people who've
done horrible things to victims and and
i think one of the things that we lose
sight of is the vast majority of people
that uh that this type of a law would
apply to
are people who are homeless they're
mentally ill they're addicted
and and i know this point has been
raised before but what we're doing here
is
we're once again using the criminal
justice system
because it's easier
than fixing homelessness it's easier
than fixing drug addiction it's easier
than
improving mental health um
and one of the things
a lot of people have had long
conversations about over the last couple
of years is are there things that we can
be doing in the criminal justice system
and with law enforcement
that would address some of these issues
at the root level
and i
i i don't know
how
holding
more of these people longer
are going to help us solve the root
problems which really do seem to be drug
addiction homelessness and mental
illness
thanks
you need you need to be in your seat
it's rule
it's rule 107.
this time we'll now move to move the
question if you in support of the motion
of octopass is amended
please say yay if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk will now call
the rule
vice chairman roy yes representative
welch
yes
representative burritt
representative pearson yes
representative green yes
clerk votes yes
representative berry yes
representative true
nay
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
representative harriet gathright no
representative sue newman
yes
representative o'hearn
representative bordenay no
representative muse
no
representative ray newman
representative heath
yes
representative conley yes
no chairman abbas
most about to pass has amended passes
who's
representative green you'll be doing the
majority
report you representative greene
at this time we'll now close the
in the committee
and just to the members the members of
the committee we don't have anything to
anyway
is
yes
the only thing i have to say
is
i do have an issue
with
changes to the criminal code
first time in this committee well
you